सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ
आई होप सो ओके
ओके सो प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस इफ आई एम
ऑडिबल इफ आई एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली
प्लीज मुझे बताइए एक बार जल्दी से फटाफट
सभी बताइए इफ आई एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली
फास्ट फास्ट फास्ट गाइस फास्ट हरी अप
जल्दी से मुझे बता दीजिए। फटाफट बता
दीजिए।
इफ आई एम ऑडिबल क्लियरली गाइस।
ओके।
मेरी आवाज
बिल्कुल क्लियर जा रही है ना? ठीक है। मैं
एक बार यहां पे अनाउंस कर देता हूं सभी
को।
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
जस्ट अ सेकंड। मैं सभी को यहां पे एक बार
इनफॉर्म कर दूं।
ओके। सो, अ लॉट ऑफ़ पीपल हैव ऑलरेडी जॉइ।
आई होप कि बाकी सभी लोग आ जाएंगे। सो सभी
को जॉइ करने देते हैं। अ
एक बार सभी जॉइ कर लेते हैं। विद देन वी
विल बी स्टार्टिंग। राइट?
ओके।
ओके। सो अ लॉट ऑफ़ पीपल हैव जॉइ ऑलरेडी। बट
जितना फर्स्ट डे को जितने लोगों ने जॉइ
किया था उतने लोग अभी फिलहाल अभी भी नहीं
है। बट आई होप कि जल्दी ही जॉइ करेंगे
सभी। देन ओनली वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग।
ओके।
हम
अभी बहुत लोगों को शायद खबर ही नहीं गई
है।
समटाइ्स YouTube जो है ना वो थोड़ा लेट
भेजता है अनाउंसमेंट जो नोटिफिकेशन है तो
कुछ लोग थोड़ा टाइम लेते हैं जॉइ करने
में। गुड गुड गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी। गुड
इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। अ वेरी
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू।
फाइनली आप लोग आ चुके हैं। सो सभी को आ
जाने देते हैं पहले एक बार।
सो कैसे रहे हैं आपके दो दिनों का इंतजार
का समय कैसा रहा आप लोगों का? हाउ वाज़ इट?
मजा आया दो दिनों में आपने रिवाइज वगैरह
सब कुछ कर लिया सब लोगों ने। थैंक यू
ब्रदर। थैंक यू। थैंक यू। थैंक यू सो मच।
चलिए। सो गाइस फाइनली अब टाइम हो चुका है।
1 मिनट हम एक्स्ट्रा ऑलरेडी एक या दो मिनट
एक्स्ट्रा ले चुके हैं। सो नाउ इट्स टाइम
टू स्टार्ट बिकॉज़ और ज्यादा वेट नहीं कर
सकते हैं। एंड जिनको आना है वो आ जाएंगे।
जो सिंसर होंगे वो आ जाएंगे। सो एक बार
मुझे फिर से बता दीजिए क्या आप सभी रियली
अगेन उसी एक्साइटमेंट के साथ इस सेशन में
जुड़े हैं जिस एक्साइटमेंट के साथ आप
फर्स्ट डे को जुड़े थे। फर्स्ट क्लास करी
थी। आर यू एक्साइटेड एट द सेम लेवल? प्लीज
लेट मी नो। सभी लोग बताइए मुझे। आर यू
एक्साइटेड टू द सेम लेवल? क्योंकि इस
ट्रेनिंग को जॉब रेडी बनाने देखो ट्रेनिंग
मैं आपको दे दूंगा। बट ट्रेनिंग को जॉब
रेडी बनाना है कि नहीं ये आपके हाथों में
है। ये मेरे हाथों में नहीं है। इट्स
टोटली अप टू यू। क्योंकि जॉब रेडी लेवल की
ट्रेनिंग अगर आपको फ्री में कोई देगा तो
वो आपसे थोड़ी एक्सपेक्टेशन रखेगा। एंड वो
एक्सपेक्टेशन आपसे मॉनिटरी या पैसे लेने
की बात नहीं है। यहां बात है आपकी
प्रेजेंस की। आपकी अटेंशन की, आपकी
डेडिकेशन की बस दैट्स इट। ओके थैंक यू
वेरी मच। बहुत बढ़िया। और जितने लोग आए हो
लाइक ठोकते चले जाना। लाइक जरूर ठोक देना
भाई। वो बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। ठीक है?
चलिए
ओके। दो काफी जोश में लग रहे हैं सब। उसको
और भी और भी ज्यादा और भी ज्यादा जोश आपके
में भर देंगे हम अभी बस थोड़ी देरों में।
तो सबसे पहला काम आपको क्या करना है? आप
सबको पता है सबसे मैंडेटरी चीज है इस
ट्रेनिंग को करने के साथ ही कि आप डेफ़on
एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे लाइव सेशन में जब
आप जाएंगे तो कोई सी भी एसओ एसओसी
एनालिस्ट वाली जो हमारी क्लास हुई है उसको
ओपन कीजिएगा उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप
जाएंगे एंड यहां पे आपको एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप मिलेगा एसओसी का स्पेशली आपके एसओसी
के लिए ग्रुप है आप इसको जरूर जॉइ करेंगे
एंड देन आपको WhatsApp एक चैनल मिलेगा
इसको आप जरूर फॉलो करेंगे इन दोनों में ही
आपके इस ग्रुप में आपको फर्दर डिटेल सारी
अपडेट्स एंड सर्टिफिकेशन से रिलेटेड एंड
जो भी चीजें आने वाली है आगे वो सब मिलेगी
एसओसी से रिलेटेड ओनली एंड चैनल पे आपको
हमारी एसओसी के साथ-साथ दूसरे अपडेट्स
दूसरी ट्रेनिंग दूसरे कोर्सेस सबके बारे
में अपडेट्स मिलेंगे। तो ये काम आपको सबसे
पहले इंपॉर्टेंट है। ये मैंडेटरी है। सभी
को कर लेना है। आई एम रिक्वेस्टिंग यू
अगेन एंड अगेन क्योंकि ये इंपॉर्टेंट है।
दूसरा ये हमारा Instagram पेज है
डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल। जाके आप इसको
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। हमसे जुड़ जाइएगा। हम
अलग-अलग तरह के एजुकेशनल रील्स एंड कंटेंट
के लिए यह हमारा एक्स का पेज है। एक्स का
प्रोफाइल है यानी कि Twitter प्रोफाइल है।
x.com dfonic accडy इस पे फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। बहुत जल्द ये इसमें बहुत कुछ
आपको देखने को मिलेगा। एंड ये जो है मेरी
खुद की प्रोफाइल है। आप चाहे तो मुझसे
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। काफी लोगों ने
कनेक्शन रिक्वेस्ट भेजी थी तो मैंने
एक्सेप्ट भी करा है। अब बहुत ज्यादा आ
चुकी थी तो कुछ लोगों के रह गए होंगे।
वापस मैं कर लूंगा। कोई टेंशन वाली बात
नहीं है। एंड द अदर थिंग इज़ कि यह हमारी
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यानी यानी कि हमारी कंपनी की
पेज है। डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी को।
आप इसको भी यहां आके फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। एंड
कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जितने भी अपडेट्स
हैं, स्टार्टअप कैसे रन करते हैं, किस
तरीके से आगे चीजें हम करेंगे वो सब कुछ
आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगा। तो यह जरूर से
जरूर कर लीजिएगा। अब मैं आपको एक जादू
दिखाता हूं। जादू है। फर्स्ट जो हमारी
क्लास हुई थी उस क्लास के रिगार्डिंग वो
जादू है और वो मैं आपको दिखाना चाहूंगा।
ठीक है?
जादू ये है कि जब आप फर्स्ट सेशन को ओपन
करेंगे फर्स्ट जो क्लास हुई थी आप सबको तो
वैसे मैंने बताया हुआ था बट स्टिल मैं
आपको वापस से बता देता हूं कि देखो ये
होती है पावर ऑफ कमिटमेंट्स। जो आपकी
कमिटमेंट है जो आपकी लर्निंग कमिटमेंट है
उसकी। फर्स्ट आपके सेशन पे ऑलमोस्ट 7000
व्यूज चले चले जा चुके हैं। वन 200
कमेंट्स लगभग होने वाले हैं। लगभग 800
लाइक्स हैं। तो ये जो जोश है ना ये कायम
रहना चाहिए। ये कंटिन्यू रहना चाहिए। तभी
मजा आएगा। Lindin पे आप जाओगे तो आप
Lindin पे देखो मैं नोटिफिकेशन आपको ओपन
करके मैं दिखा देता हूं। देखो पीपल आर
पोस्टिंग जो लोग हैं पोस्ट कर रहे हैं
एसओसी के बारे में। एसओसी के इस ट्रेनिंग
के बारे में। में Lindin पे पोस्ट कर रहे
हैं। हमारे को टैग कर रहे हैं। एंड यही
जोश एंड यही जज्बा आपकी चाहिए ताकि मैं
आपको एक अलग लेवल पे कंटेंट डिलीवर कर
पाऊं। दैट्स इट। बदले में यही मांग रहा
हूं और कुछ भी नहीं मांग रहा आपको और आपको
देना तो पड़ेगा। इस चीज में देना पड़ेगा।
आप देख सकते हो बहुत सारे लोगों ने पोस्ट
करा है, टैग करा है। तो ये आपको हर क्लास
के साथ हर सेशन के साथ करना है। जैसे किसी
ने मान लो कि टैग करा। टैग करके उन्होंने
की पॉइंट्स लिखे हैं। पहले सेशन से जो
चीजें उन्होंने सीखी है, जोज चीजें
उन्होंने नॉलेज ली है, उसके की पॉइंट्स
मेंशन करिए। एंड उन की पॉइंट्स के बाद
उन्होंने हमें टैग भी करा है कि आपने
एग्जैक्टली फर्स्ट सेशन से क्या-क्या? कुछ
लोगों ने मीडियम के आर्टिकल्स लिखे हैं।
कुछ लोगों ने Instagram पे पोस्ट किया था।
तो इट्स ग्रेट। काफी अच्छा है। अगर ऐसा आप
कर रहे हैं तो ये आपके लिए बहुत
बेनिफिशियल होने वाला है।
चलिए।
अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे डे टू पे हमारे एंड
ज्यादा बिना लेट किए हुए हम आज के सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं। एंड आज के सेशन में और
भी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हम अ देखने वाले
हैं, समझने वाले हैं। एंड अगर आपको अ
थोड़ा भी इंटरेस्ट होगा एसओसी को लेके तो
आपको बहुत मजा आने वाला है। इट्स इट्स माय
प्रॉमिस टू यू। अब देखो ये जो पूरी एसओसी
की गेम है ये जो पूरी एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग
है ये एसओसी एनालिस्ट लेवल वन की ट्रेनिंग
है। ये समझ लो कि तुम पेड ट्रेनिंग कर रहे
हो। तुम इस चीज को समझ के रखो कि यू आर
डूइंग अ पेड ट्रेनिंग। यू आर नॉट डूइंग अ
फ्री ट्रेनिंग। पेड ट्रेनिंग में
सिंसियरनेस होती है ना। पैसे दिए होते हैं
यहां पैसे खर्च हुए होते हैं। तो बहुत मजा
आता है। लगता है कि क्लास करना चाहिए। है
ना? और सेम कंटेंट आपको मिलता है पेड
ट्रेनिंग वाली। यहां पे फ्री में आपको मिल
रहा है। वही सेम कंटेंट मिल रहा है। तो
इसको उसी सिंसियरनेस से आपको करना है
अटेंड। अभी देखो फर्स्ट डे 300 लोग लाइव
थे ऑलमोस्ट 300 से ज्यादा। बट आज सेकंड डे
200 250 के आसपास होने वाले हैं। बट स्टिल
इट्स गुड। अगर आप सिंसियर हैं तो मुझे पता
है 300 लोग भी आ जाएंगे, 400 भी आ जाएंगे।
बट मैं बस इतना कहना चाहता हूं कि मैं
आपको ये ट्रेनिंग एक पूरे स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे
में कराऊंगा। तो आपको उसी तरीके से करना
है। आपको अपना दिमाग नहीं लगाना है। अभी
एक्सप्लोर कीजिए। टॉपिक्स को एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए। ट्रेनिंग के बाद आपको जो-जो
टॉपिक्स एक्सप्लोर करने हैं आप कीजिए।
बिलकुल कीजिए। आने वाले टाइम में आपको
टास्क दूंगा। अब एसओसी की जो रोल है,
एसओसी की जो पूरी ये
पाथ है आपकी, ये पूरी जो जर्नी है, इसमें
थ्यरी भी होंगे, प्रैक्टिकल भी होंगे,
लैब्स भी होंगे। तीनों चीजें होंगी। तो
आपको धीरे-धीरे मैं आगे लेकर जाऊंगा। एकदम
से छलांग नहीं लगानी है। नहीं तो यहां पे
जो बिगिनर्स हैं उनको समझ में नहीं आएगा।
और मैं मान के चलता हूं यहां पे मोस्टली
बिगिनर्स प्लस इंटरमीडिएट लेवल के ही
लर्नर्स हैं। एडवांस वाले तो ऑब्वियस सी
बात है वो नहीं सीखेंगे। उनका कोई मतलब
नहीं बनता है। हां अगर वो अ और भी ज्यादा
थोड़ी सी एनहांस करना चाहते हैं वो
बिल्कुल आ सकते हैं। नो इशूज़। इवन यू आर
एन एसओसी आप आ सकते हैं बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स
के लिए। कोर कांसेप्ट्स के लिए जो शायद
आपको अभी तक नहीं पता होगा। आप टूल्स पे
काम जरूर करते होंगे। बट ऐसी कई ऐसे
टॉपिक्स एंड कांसेप्ट्स होंगे जो आपको इस
ट्रेनिंग में पता चलेगा। ये बात याद
रखिएगा। तो मैं आपको जिस लेवल पे जिस
तरीके से लेकर जाऊंगा सेम तरीके से आपको
चलना है। आपको हड़बड़ाना नहीं है, घबराना
नहीं है। देखो अब मैं अगर कोई थ्योरी
कंटेंट जब आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं, डिलीवर कर
रहा हूं जो थ्योरी पार्ट है। अब उसमें अगर
तुम ये टेंशन में आ जाओगे इस बात को लेके
कि सर थ्यरी नहीं पढ़ना है सर। अ
प्रैक्टिकल करना है तो ऐसे करोगे तो मैं
आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि तुम अभी ही
छोड़ दो इस ट्रेनिंग को क्योंकि ये
ट्रेनिंग तुम्हारे लिए है ही नहीं फिर
क्योंकि इस ट्रेनिंग को मैं अपने
अकॉर्डिंग कराऊंगा ना कि जो कुछ लोग चाहते
हैं कि बस प्रैक्टिकल देख लो प्रैक्टिकल
कर लो वो तो ठीक है प्रैक्टिकल में क्या
है यार मैं एसआईएम टूल्स प्रैक्टिकल करा
दूंगा दो चार फिशिंग के टूल्स टेक्निक्स
बता दूंगा दो चार मैलवेयर एनालिसिस
मालवेयस डिटेक्शन के कर दूंगा हो गया खत्म
ये अगर आप चाहते हो तो आपके लिए ट्रेनिंग
नहीं है। बट अगर आप चाहते हो पूरे फुल
फ्लेज़ में आगे बढ़ना तो आपके लिए ट्रेनिंग
है। एंड मैंने जब आपको बोला है कि मैं
आपको एसओसी एल1 के जॉब रोल के लेवल तक की
दूंगा ट्रेनिंग तो लेवल तक ही दूंगा। बस
दैट्स इट। मैं इतना ही जानता हूं। अब इससे
ज्यादा मैं कुछ नहीं बोलूंगा। ठीक है।
अच्छा सबने लाइक भी ठोक दिया। क्या बात
है। बहुत अच्छी बात है। गुड इवनिंग। गुड
इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू।
गुड इवनिंग। अ
थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू ब्रदर
ऐप पर भी रिसोर्स आ जाएंगे बट अभी फिलहाल
ग्रुप में ही मिलेंगे आपको WhatsApp ग्रुप
में तो WhatsApp ग्रुप में आते हैं। अब
देखो एक छोटा सा बट इंपॉर्टेंट रीकैप मार
लेते हैं। एक छोटा सा बट इंपॉर्टेंट रीकैप
मार लेते हैं। आप सबको बताया था मैंने कि
बेसिकली एसओसी क्या होता है? एसओसी एक
डेडिकेटेड फैसिलिटी होती है जिसको कौन
ऑपरेट करता है? एक स्पेशलाइज्ड सिक्योरिटी
टीम। एसओसी एक कोई सिंगल बंदा नहीं होता।
याद रखिएगा और एसओसी कोई पोस्ट नहीं होती
है। एसओसी एनालिस्ट का पोस्ट होगा, एसओसी
इंजीनियर का पोस्ट होगा, एसओसी मैनेजर का
पोस्ट होगा, डायरेक्टर का पोस्ट होगा।
एसओसी का पोस्ट नहीं होता है। ठीक है? तो
ये कंफ्यूजन हटा दीजिएगा। कोई पूछेगा,
अच्छा तुम एसओसी के पोस्ट पे हो? एसओसी के
अरे नहीं भाई, एसओसी के पोस्ट पे थोड़ी ना
हूं। एसओसी तो खुद एक डेडिकेटेड एक
एनवायरमेंट एक फैसिलिटी है। जहां
स्पेशलाइज्ड सिक्योरिटी टीम काम करती है।
अब ये टीम का काम है कंटीन्यूअसली
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के नेटवर्क रिसोर्सेज
सिक्योरिटी एंड एनी काइंड ऑफ़ सस् सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी को मॉनिटर करते रहना। और किसी
भी तरह के डैमेज से बचाना। अब यह जो टीम
है यह 24 * 7 काम करती है। हर दिन 24 * 7
काम करती है। इसीलिए एसओसीस के लिए रोल्स
जो एसओसीस के रोल्स होते हैं उनके लिए
वैकेंसीज ज्यादा होती हैं कंपनीज़ के अंदर
में। अब ये वैकेंसीज इसलिए ज्यादा होती है
क्योंकि मल्टीपल शिफ्ट में काम करना पड़ता
है। अब यार दो शिफ्ट में बंदे कम से कम दो
चाहिए। चलो दो नहीं एक बैकअप बंदा भी
रखेंगे। कहीं एक ने छुट्टी ले ली। एक एक
कंपनी के अंदर में अगर दो ही एसओसी रखते
हैं दो शिफ्ट के लिए और एक ने मान लो
छुट्टी मार ली कैसे होगा काम तो तीन चार
रखने पड़ेंगे बैकअप के लिए रखना पड़ेगा है
ना तो ये पूरी जो ये जो रिक्वायरमेंट है
ना ये आपके रोल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट को
बढ़ाती है ये जो है ना आपके अ इस जॉब रोल
के रिक्वायरमेंट को बढ़ाती है। अब जेनेरिक
ज अगर जनरल ड्यूटीज़ देखा जाए एसओसी
एनालिस्ट की। देखो मैं आपको यह जो अह मैं
आपको ये जो एसओसी एनालिस्ट का ये पूरा
ट्रेनिंग है ये जो पूरा कोर्स है ये मैं
आपको एक एक लैडर जैसे सीढ़ियां चढ़ते हैं ना
उस तरीके से चढ़ाऊंगा।
धीरे पहले कॉन्सेप्ट्स आपके क्लियर
करूंगा। धीरे-धीरे इसकी सीवियरिटी बढ़ेगी।
धीरे-धीरे कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी बढ़ेगी इसकी। याद
रखिएगा। अभी आपको बहुत मजा आ रहा होगा।
ईजी लग रहा होगा। बट अगर आप अभी के
क्लासेस को मिस कर देंगे ना और अभी के
क्लासेस में सिंसियर नहीं रहेंगे, अभी के
क्लासेस को सीरियस तरीके से नहीं लेंगे ना
तो बाद में जब ये कॉम्प्लेक्स होता चला
जाएगा तो आपको कुछ समझ में नहीं आएगा। तो
आपसे मेरी एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि अगर आप अभी
से सिंसियर हो के और एकदम ध्यान देके
करेंगे तो बाद की चीजें ना आपको बच्चों
जैसा दिखेगा लगेगा। एकदम बच्चों जैसा
लगेगा। आपको लगेगा अरे एसएसवी में ऐसी
चीजें होती हैं। इतनी इजी चीजें होती हैं।
मैं क्यों नहीं कर रहा था अभी तक एसओसी
वाली चीजें? मैं क्यों नहीं एसओसी
एनालिस्ट के लिए प्रिपेयर करके जॉब अप्लाई
करके एटलीस्ट साइबर सिक्योरिटी में घुस तो
जाऊं। अब आप लोगों का एक सिंसियर कंसर्न
है। ठीक है? इफ यू आर इफ आपको क्या है? एक
सिंसियर कंसर्न है आप लोगों का। वो
सिंसियर कंसर्न क्या है कि सर एज अ फ्रेशर
जॉब नहीं लगती। सर एज अ फ्रेशर जॉब नहीं
लगती। एज अ फ्रेशर कोई किसी को जॉब नहीं
देता है। यह सिंसियर कंसर्न है। बट अगर आप
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट बनते हैं, एक एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट की ट्रेनिंग ले लेते हैं। एक
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट के लिए प्रिपेयर करते
हैं, तो आपके पास एक बहुत अच्छा विंडो ओपन
होगा। एक बहुत एक एक रास्ता खुलेगा जो
आपको एंट्री दिला सकता है इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। एंड फिर आप अदर रोल्स के लिए
जाइए ना। ऐसा नहीं है कि आप एसओसी रोल में
आ गए तो आप एसओसी में ही रह जाएंगे जिंदगी
भर। यू विल हैव मल्टीपल डिफरेंट ऑप्शंस
फदर। आप इसमें भी आगे बढ़ के आप इंजीनियर,
डायरेक्टर, मैनेजर बनके बड़े लेवल पे जा
सकते हैं। इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन बन सकते हैं।
तो पूरी इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस की दुनिया खाली
है। थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस की दुनिया खाली है।
क्या-क्या नहीं है? सब खाली। सब तुम्हारे
लिए वेट करेंगी। स्किल्स ले लो। मैं
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं स्किल्स ले लो। इतना
बोल रहा हूं तो समझो। ठीक है ना? इस चीज
को थोड़ा सा समझो। जानम समझा करो प्लीज।
इतना समझ लोगे तो तुम्हारा भला हो जाएगा।
मैं मैं सच बता रहा हूं। इतना समझ लोगे
भला हो जाएगा आपका। बस
इट्स ओके। राइट
इस कोर्स के बाद सर क्या आप हमें रेफरल
दोगे फॉर स्टार्टिंग हर करियर? बताओ भाई।
मेरे से रेफरल भी पूछ रहे हैं यह भाई। कौन
है यह?
फ्यू कोलियो जो भी आईडी से हैं मतलब भाई
एक तो मैं ट्रेनिंग दूं तुम्हें बिल्कुल
फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट जॉब लेवल की ट्रेनिंग दूं
उसमें तुम मुझसे रेफरल भी मांग रहे हो कि
सर आप मुझसे रे मुझे हमें रेफरल देंगे
क्या अब मैं बोल दूं कि हां रेफरल दूंगा
और नहीं दूंगा तो तुम ऊपर से मुझे उल्टा
उल्टा सुनाने लगोगे तुम लोग ऑनलाइन अरे सर
ने बोला था रेफरल देंगे घंटा कुछ दिया
नहीं ये सब चीजें हो जाएंगी तो क्यों इतनी
ज्यादा एक्सपेक्टेशन रखनी एक आपको इतनी
भयानक ट्रेनिंग िंग मिल रही है। आपको क्या
लगता है इस ट्रेनिंग की वैल्यू क्या होगी?
इसकी ट्रेनिंग की कोई वैल्यू नहीं है।
प्राइसेस है। कोई नहीं देता भाई। ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग नहीं देगा कोई। बस तो अब तो ठीक
है। देख लेंगे रेफरल का अगर ऐसा कुछ होगा
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट। चलो मैं आपको ये भी बोलता
हूं कि ट्रेनिंग जब खत्म होगी ये तो लास्ट
में हम इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन की भी क्लासेस
कराएंगे। अब बोला हूं। अब उसमें मैं आपको
रेफरेंस देने की बात नहीं करूंगा। उसमें
मैं आपको किस तरीके से अप्लाई करना है जॉब
के लिए कहां पे अप्लाई करना है किन चीजों
का ध्यान रखना है रिज्यूुमे के अंदर में
ताकि ऑटोमेटेड आपका ऑटोमेटिक वे में
Lindin पे रिज्यूम आपका अ अनसलेक्ट ना हो
जाए या
आपका रिज्यूम जो है वो रिजेक्ट ना हो जाए
वो भी मैं आपको बता दूंगा। अब ठीक है
अब ठीक है भाई एवरीथिंग इज गुड नाउ
एवरीथिंग इज़ फाइन नाउ कभी भी दिक्कत है
बताओ इतने में खुशी मिली। थैंक यू ऑफ कोड।
धन्यवाद भाई।
ऑफकोड बोल रहे हैं योर स्माइल इज क्यूट।
क्या बात है। थैंक्स।
ठीक है। चलिए अब डेली ड्यूटीज एज एन एसओसी
एनालिस्ट क्या होता है? मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। और हर सेशन आपका एक से 1ढ़ घंटे का ही
रखेंगे। क्योंकि कई लोगों ने मेरे को बोला
है कि सर तीन-4 घंटे की मत करना नहीं तो
हम बोर बोर हो जाते हैं थोड़ा सा ज्यादा
लंबा हो जाता है। लव यू टू गाइस लव यू टू
डेली ड्यूटीज बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट। आप
डिटेक्ट एंड प्रिवेंट करते हैं डेटा
स्टीलर इंजेक्शन ऑन अ को वर्कर्स लैपटॉप।
कोई आपका कोवर्कर है, आपका कोलीग है। उसके
लैपटॉप पर कोई डाटा स्टीलर या कोई तरह का
कोई किसी तरह से इनफेक्ट हुआ है, तो उसको
डिटेक्ट एंड प्रिवेंट आप करते हैं। अब
फिशिंग कैंपेनस को एनालाइज करते हैं और
उसको स्टॉप करने का काम करते हैं। ये भी
आपका काम होता है। फिशिंग कैंपेनेंस है
उनको एनालाइज किया। एंटी फिशिंग टूल्स,
एंटी फिशिंग सॉलशंस आती है। वो सब हम
देखेंगे। वो सब हम जानेंगे। उससे आप यह
काम करते हैं। 281 पीपल आर नाउ हियर। क्या
बात है गाइस? 300 पूरी करना जरूरी है।
मुझे लगता है कर दोगे तो मजा आएगा। टू अगर
300 लोग आ गए तो समझो कि मैं मान के
चलूंगा कि सेम लेवल ऑफ एनर्जी अभी भी है।
फिशिंग कैंपेन को आप एनालाइज अब इधर ध्यान
दे लो। अभी थोड़ा हम अब एकदम रेगुलर इस पे
फोकस करने वाले हैं। तो अभी इधर ध्यान दे
दो। फिशिंग कैंपेन को एनालाइज करते हैं।
फिशिंग कैंपेन को स्टॉप करते हैं। बिग
इंसिडेंट जैसे कि फुल स्केल अगर रैंसमवेयर
अटैक होता है तो उसमें पार्टिसिपेट आपको
करना होता है। अगर कोई फुल स्केल
रैंसमवेयर अटैक हो गया तो उसको कैसे
मिटिगेट करना है? एस्केलेट करना है
सिक्योरिटी एल2 को, L3 को उन सब पे आप काम
करते हैं। टीम अप विथ योर टीममेट्स। आप
अपने टीममेट्स के साथ टीम अप करके
डिटेक्शन रूल्स एंड ऑटोमेशन बनाते हैं जो
कि बेसिकली सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स या L2
L3 का काम मेनली L2 L3 का काम होता है।
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स भी उसमें इन्वॉल्वड
होते हैं। बट आप अपने टीममेट्स के साथ टीम
अप हो जाते हैं। इसके लिए भी गो बियोंड
साइबर एंड अंडरस्टैंड हाउ कंपनीज़ ऑपरेट
फ्रॉम द इनसाइड। कंपनीज़ कैसे ऑपरेट करती
हैं इनसाइड से? ये भी आप आप इस पे भी फोकस
करते हैं। अब एज अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट L1 टिए
वन का मतलब यहां पे L1 से मैं बातें कर
रहा हूं। एज अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल वन आई एम
टॉकिंग अबाउट एल वन टियर वन मतलब एल वन यू
आर द फर्स्ट रिसोंडर जैसा कि मैंने आपको
बताया भी था यू मॉनिटर ट्राईग एस्केलेट
एंड डॉक्यूमेंट एव्री सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट
आपका सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट काम है मॉनिटर करना
ट्राई करना मतलब उसको उस पर्टिकुलर अलर्ट
को ट्राईग करना मींस एक्सेप्ट या रिजेक्ट
करना एस्केलेट करना अगर वो एक्सेप्ट करते
हो दैट इज इज़ सेंस समथिंग सीरियस देन
एस्केलेट कीजिए या अगर कोई हाई सीवियरिटी
की कुछ अलर्ट आई है एंड डॉक्यूमेंट एंड
उसकी डॉक्यूमेंट यानी लॉग क्रिएट करना
बिना उसके आप कुछ भी नहीं है। अब
क्या-क्या है? मॉनिटर करना एसआईएम ईडीआर
या एक्सडीआर फायर वॉल ईमेल अलर्ट्स इन सब
चीजों के। अब यहां पे अ
ये जो टूल्स हैं इसके ऊपर भी हम काम
करेंगे। इसके ऊपर में भी हम देखेंगे। इनको
भी देखेंगे कि एसआईएम वगैरह ईडीआर एक्सआर
ये सब क्या होते हैं। वैलिडेट अलर्ट्स
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है। इसको
वैलिडेट करना क्रिटिकल अलर्ट्स या
क्रिटिकल इवेंट्स को
एसएल
एसओसी लेवल टू या इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर्स
को जो है उनको एस्केलेट करना। जो इंसिडेंट
रिस्पॉन्डर्स होते हैं या एसओसी लेवल टू
के एंप्लई होते हैं उनको एस्केलेट करना
अगर बहुत क्रिटिकल है तो एंड एवरीथिंग को
लॉक करना। तो बेसिकली क्या होता है? L1,
L2, फिर L3 होती है। फिर इंसिडेंट
रेस्पोंडर्स होते हैं। एंड देन जो है
लास्ट में थ्रेड हंटर्स या ब्लू टीमर्स जो
मेन कोर टीम होती है वो होते हैं। यहां तक
सब कुछ क्लियर हो गया होगा। राइट? अब आते
हैं यहां पे मेन काम हमारा एसओसी टीम का
क्या होता है? मेन काम है आपके एसओसी टीम
का डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस को इंटैक्ट
रखना। दैट्स इट। डिटेक्शन और इन और
रिस्पांस को इंटैक्ट रखना। अब इस चीज में
तीन चीजें एकिस्ट करती है जो बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है। पहला है पीपल
ये जो आपका मैं
हाईलाइटर कर लेता हूं पेन कर लेता हूं।
पहला है आपका ये पीपल। दूसरा है आपका ये
प्रोसेस एंड तीसरा है आपका यह टेक्नोलॉजी।
यह तीन चीजें दिस थ्री थिंग्स आर द थिंग।
मैं इसको यहां पर
इरेज करके यहां से मैं हाईलाइटर ले लेता
हूं।
पीपल
प्रोसेससेस एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी थ्री थिंग्स ये एकिस्ट करते
हैं इन एन एसओसी एनवायरमेंट। ये तीन
चीजें। अब तीन चीजों का क्या मतलब है? ये
भी हम जानेंगे। ये तीन चीज़ एग्जैक्टली
क्या होते हैं? ये छोटे-छोटे कांसेप्ट्स
आपके लिए इतने इंपॉर्टेंट है ना। इसके
बिना एसओसी का फाउंडेशन बेकार है। एसओसी
का कांसेप्ट बेकार है। एंड आप ऐसी ही
चीजें जब नहीं जानते हैं और इंटरव्यू के
लिए जाते हैं और रिजेक्ट हो जाते हैं तो
आप यह बोलते हैं कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी में
जॉब ही नहीं है। आप यह बोलते हैं कि अरे
यार ये इंटरव्यू तो क्रैक ही नहीं कर पा
रहा हूं। इतनी चीजें जानता हूं फिर भी
नहीं क्रैक कर पा रहा हूं। अरे फालतू के
क्वेश्चन बस करते हैं। इन चीजों के कारण
ही क्योंकि ये बेसिक चीजें यू डोंट नो। ये
बेसिक चीजें यू डोंट वांट टू नो। ये बेसिक
चीजें यू डोंट वांट टू मेमोराइज। यू डोंट
वांट टू आप अपने दिमाग में इसको नहीं
डालना चाहते। सो ये चीजें अगर आपकी क्लियर
है ना इंटरव्यू में कोई आपको कोई आपको ना
मना नहीं कर सकता। आपको कोई रिजेक्ट नहीं
कर सकता है। बस ध्यान दे लेना इतना।
अ टीम ऑफ़ प्रोफेशनल इंडिविजुअल्स वर्किंग
ऑन स्टेट ऑफ़ आर्ट सिक्योरिटी टूल्स। मतलब
एक प्रोफेशनल इंडिविजुअल्स का एक टीम
पीपल। एक स्टेट ऑफ आर्ट सिक्योरिटी टूल्स
टेक्नोलॉजी इन द प्रेजेंस ऑफ प्रॉपर
प्रोसेससेस प्रोसेस इज व्हाट मेक्स अ
एसओसी एनवायरमेंट। ये तीनों का
इन्वॉल्वमेंट एक टीम ऑफ पीपल वो पीपल हो
गया। एक स्पेसिफिक प्रोसेस के अंदर सारा
काम करना प्रोसेस हो गया। एंड स्पेसिफिक
टूल्स के ऊपर ऑपरेट करना टेक्नोलॉजी हो
गई। तो ये तीनों चीजें इंक्लूड हो जाती है
आपके एसओसी एनवायरमेंट के अंदर में। अब
एसओसी का जो हायरार्की है वो क्या है? इस
पूरे पर्टिकुलर इस चीज का हायरार्की क्या
है? वो मैं आपको हायरार्की भी दिखा देता
हूं। अब ये हायरार्की आपको यहां पे थोड़ी
सी कट रही होगी। मैं इसको ज़ूम आउट कर देता
हूं ताकि आपका ये कटे ना एटलीस्ट
यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं। ये आपको अब यहां पे दिख रही होगी। तो
ये जो हायरार्की है इस हायरार्की में क्या
है? आप यहां पे देखो। पहले एसओसी लेवल
लेवल वन आपकी पहले एसओसी लेवल वन आ जाती
है। मैं इसको ऐसे करने की कोशिश करता हूं।
मैं इसको यहां से थोड़ी देर के लिए यहां
पे शिफ्ट कर देता हूं। ठीक है? अब आपको ये
प्रॉपर दिखेगी। ठीक है? राइट? तो पहले
एसओसी लेवल वन आ जाती है। फिर लेवल टू आ
जाती है। लेवल थ्री होता है। देन यहां पे
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर होते हैं। देन यहां
पे डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर होते हैं। ये तीन
चीजें ये होती है। सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर,
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर। अब सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर जो है वो सफिशिएंट होते हैं।
समटाइ्स डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर की जरूरत पड़ती
है। अदरवाइज इसकी जरूरत नहीं भी होती है।
इट्स ओके चलता है। उसके ऊपर एसओसी मैनेजर
या एसओसी डायरेक्टर्स होते हैं एंड उसके
ऊपर होते हैं सीआईएसओस
जो चीफ इनेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर होते हैं
सीआईएसओस जो बिजनेस को हैंडल करते हैं जो
बेसिकली बिनेस को मैनेज करते हैं। तो यह
एक पूरा का पूरा हायरार्की है जो एसओसी के
टीम के साथ डील आप करेंगे जो एसओसी टीम के
अंदर में पाया जाता है। अब अब यहां पे आ
जाते हैं पीपल। सबसे पहले तीनों चीजों को
हम देखेंगे। पीपल, प्रोसेस एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी। ये तीन चीजें हैं। राइट? सो
पहले अब हम पीपल को देखते हैं। व्हाट आर द
पीपल? तो इस पीपल के अंदर में यही सारे
रोल्स आते हैं। जो रोल्स मैंने पहले भी
बताए थे। आज मैं फिर से आपको थोड़ा सा
क्लियर करता हूं। एसओसी लेवल दो पहला रोल
है आपका
ये रही एसओसी लेवल वन मैं यहां पे
हाईलाइटर यूज़ कर लेता हूं एसओसी लेवल वन
ये पहला रोल है आपका एसओसी लेवल वन दूसरा
है एसओसी लेवल टू एसओसी लेवल थ्री
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर
एंड एसओसी मैनेजर देन सीआईएसओ एंड ऑल अब
लेवल वन क्या करते हैं? इसको ध्यान
देखिएगा। ध्यान रखिएगा इसको। इन चीजों
कीेंस है भाई। आपसे आपका आप L1 के लिए
प्रिपेयर कर रहे हैं। इसका मतलब ये नहीं
कि सिर्फ L1 से रिलेटेड आपसे क्वेश्चन
पूछेगा। ये बात हमेशा ध्यान रखिएगा। इट्स
नॉटेंट। इट्स नॉट मैंडेटरी कि आप L1 के
लिए प्रिपेयर कर रहे हैं। तो सिर्फ L1 से
रिलेटेड क्वेश्चंस ही करेगा इंटरव्यूअर।
आपसे थोड़ी बहुत जो है वो L2 से रिलेटेड
चीजें पूछ सकता है, टच कर सकता है। तो
आपको पता होना चाहिए या उसके ऊपर के
हायरार्की को तो एनीथिंग डिटेक्टेड
एनीथिंग डिटेक्टेड बाय द सिक्योरिटी
सॉल्यूशन वुड पास थ्रू दी एनालिस्ट
फर्स्ट। कोई भी सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन जैसे
आपका ईडीआर हो गया, एक्सडीआर हो गया,
एसआईएम टूल्स हो गए। अगर वो डिटेक्ट करती
है अलर्ट कोई तो सबसे पहले एस एल1 के थ्रू
ही होके हो जाएगा। दीज़ आर द फर्स्ट
रेस्पोंडेंस टू एनी डिटेक्शन। एसओसी लेवल
वन एनालिस्ट परफॉर्म बेसिक अलर्ट ट्रैक टू
डिटरमाइन इफ अ स्पेसिफिक डिटेक्शन इज़
हार्मफुल। दे आल्सो रिपोर्ट दिस डिटेक्शन
थ्रू द प्रॉपर चैनल्स। सबसे पहला इनका काम
होता है रिपोर्ट करना। इनको अलर्ट को यह
पता लगाना अलर्ट के बारे में कि एक्चुअली
ये सही है कि गलत है। सही है तो प्रॉपर
रिपोर्ट डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करना एंड क्रिटिकल
है तो आगे फॉरवर्ड करना। अगर हैंडल हो जा
रहा है तो वहीं पे डॉक्यूमेंट करके उसको
रिॉल्व करना। काउंटर मेजर करना। L1 का काम
है। L2 क्या है? व्हाई लेवल वन डज़ द
फर्स्ट लेवल एनालिसिस सम डिटेक्शंस मे
रिक्वायर डीपर इन्वेस्टिगेशन। जब डीपर
इन्वेस्टिगेशन की बात आती है, सभी लोग इधर
ध्यान देंगे। चैट से ज्यादा अभी इधर ध्यान
देंगे। ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है। अगर
कोई डीपर इन्वेस्टिगेशन की बात आती है, तो
वो लेवल टू के एनालिसिस करते हैं। लेवल टू
एनालिस्ट हेल्प देम डीप डाइव डीपर इंटू
इन्वेस्टिगेशंस एंड को-रिलेट द डेटा फ्रॉम
मल्टीपल डेटा सोर्स टू परफॉर्म अ प्रॉपर
एनालिसिस। अलग-अलग तरह डेटा सोर्स से डेटा
कलेक्ट करते हैं। लॉग से डेटा कलेक्ट करते
हैं और उस पे डीपर इन्वेस्टिगेशन करने का
काम लेवल टू का होता है। लेवल थ्री वाले
क्या करते हैं? लेवल थ्री एल थ्री
एनालिस्ट आर एक्सपीरियंस्ड प्रोफेशनल। आप
ही जो है ना लेवल वन वाले जब 2 साल, एक
साल, डेढ़ साल, 2 साल काम कर लोगे तो आप
एक्सपीरियंस कैटेगरी में चले जाओगे लेवल
थ्री में। एंड आप क्या करोगे? एक्सपीरियंस
प्रोफेशनल हु प्रोएक्टिवली लुक फॉर एनी
थ्रेट इंडिकेटर्स एंड सपोर्ट इन इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस एक्टिविटी।
किसी भी तरह के थ्रेट इंडिकेटर्स को ये
कंटीन्यूअसली मॉनिटर करते हैं। एंड
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस में भी हेल्प करते हैं।
मतलब कोई इंसिडेंट हुआ उसको रिसोंड करने
में जो इंसिडेंट रिसोंडर का काम होता है
ना उनके भी काम में ये हेल्प करते हैं। द
क्रिटिकल सीवियरिटी डिटेक्शन रिपोर्टेड
बाय लेवल वन एंड लेवल टू एनालिस्ट आर ऑफेन
सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंस दैट नीड डिटेल्ड
रिस्पांस इंक्लूडिंग कंटेनमेंट, इरेडिकेशन
एंड रिकवरी। मतलब किसी अटैक को कंटेन करना
है, इरेडिकेट करना है या रिकवरी करनी है
उससे तो उस केस में लेवल थ्री वाले जो है
प्रोएक्टिवली काम करते हैं। जैसे मान लो
कोई बहुत बड़ा रैंसमवेयर अटैक हो गया किसी
कंपनी के ऊपर। फाइल्स लॉक हो गई। फाइल्स
सारी डिलीट हो रही है या उसको हाइड किया
जा रहा है। उस केस में एसओ एसओसी का लेवल
थ्री जो एनालिस्ट है वो बहुत ही ज्यादा
जोश में आएगा हरकत में एंड अपने काम को
करेगा। रिकवरी करने की कोशिश करेगा। उस
चीज को कंटेन करने की कोशिश करेगा
रैंसवेयर को एंड उसको कंप्लीटली हटाने की
कोशिश करेगा। दैट्स इट। अब आते हैं
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर। अब देखो सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर का काम क्यों होता है? अब भैया
ये जो लेवल वन, लेवल टू, लेवल थ्री वाले
हैं ये अलर्ट, ट्रायग ये सब काम किस चीज
पे कर रहे हैं? मुझे बताइए। अगर अभी तक
आपने सिंसियरली ये चीज पढ़ा है तो मुझे
अभी पता चल जाएगा कितने लोग कितने सिंसियर
हैं। ये जो लेवल वन टू थ्री वाले एनालिस्ट
हैं ये जो अलर्ट का अलर्ट देख रहे हैं। ये
जो चीजों को देख रहे हैं कि क्या अलर्ट
आया है या जो प्रोसेससेस कर रहे हैं,
लॉग्स बना रहे हैं या जो भी चीजें कर रहे
हैं। ये किस चीज पे कर रहे हैं? लेट मी
नो।
बताइए मुझे यह किस चीज पर कर रहे हैं? यह
जो अलर्ट अलर्ट एंड ऑल मतलब यह देख रहे
हैं एनीथिंग डिटेक्टेड बाय द सिक्योरिटी
सॉल्यूशन वुड पास थ्रू दी एनालिस्ट तो किस
चीज पे कर रहे हैं?
लाइक टेक्नोलॉजी पे कर रहे हैं एसआईएम
टूल्स या सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस जो होते हैं
उस पे कर रहे हैं। बिल्कुल सही।
बिल्कुल एब्सोलुटली राइट। जो भी टूल्स है
ना जो एसआईएम टूल्स हैं या जो भी
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस एक कंपनी यूज कर रही
है। कंपनी कोई सी भी सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन
यूज कर सकती है। कोई सा भी स्प्लंक किसी
भी तरह का एक्सडीआर किसी भी तरह का ईडीआर
किसी भी कंपनी का ईडीआर सॉल्यूशन एक्सडीआर
सॉल्यूशन यूज कर सकती है। वो उसकी अपनी
मर्जी है। तो ये टूल्स पे काम कर रहे हैं।
ये एक ऑटोमेटेड टूल पे काम कर रहे हैं। तो
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर जो होते हैं उसी टूल
को कंटीन्यूस
सही कॉन्फ़िगर्ड है कि नहीं? सही से काम कर
रही है कि नहीं, सही से डिप्लॉयड है कि
नहीं? सारे सिक्योरिटी अपडेट्स एंड सारी
चीजें स्मूथली काम कर रही है कि नहीं,
इसका देखरेख का काम करना सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर का रोल होता है। यानी कि जो
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स होते हैं, वह
पर्टिकुलर सॉफ्टवेयर एंड सॉलशंस को सही से
काम करने के लिए
रिस्पांसिबल होते हैं। [हंसी]
अब सोचो ना हम किसी टूल पे काम कर रहे
हैं। जस्ट इमेजिन मतलब इमेजिन करो यार
जस्ट इमेजिन आप जिस घर में रह रहे हो। अब
उस घर की मरम्मत नहीं कराओगे। उस घर उस घर
को टाइम टू टाइम रनोवेट थोड़ा नहीं
कराओगे। पेंट पॉलिश पोचारा नहीं मारोगे तो
घर की क्या हाल होगी? घर बेकार हो जाएगा।
जिस घर में आप रह रहे हो। है ना? जो घर
आपको सिक्योरिटी दे रहा है। तो वही पोचारा
और ये जो सफाई एंड सही से सब कुछ है ना वो
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर करता है। उन टूल्स के
दिस सॉलशंस नीड डेप्लॉयमेंट एंड
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। उन टूल को कॉन्फ़िगर करना, वो
सही से पैच करना, कोई पैच की रिक्वायरमेंट
है वो करना। एंड अगर मतलब किसी तरह की कोई
अ स्पेसिफिक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन चाहिए और उसके
स्मूथ ऑपरेशन के लिए वो सब काम करना
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर करता है। सो
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर उन टूल्स को टूल्स के
लिए काम करता है जिस टूल पे एसओसी L1, L2,
L3 काम करते हैं अलर्ट के लिए, ऑटोमेशन के
लिए या जो भी ये सब प्रोसेस है पूरे
प्रोसेससेस के लिए। तो उन टूल्स को सही से
ऑपरेट कराने के लिए हेल्प हेल्प करते हैं
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स। जो भी जैसे एसआईएम
टूल्स हैं आपके एसडीआर टूल है इडीआर टूल्स
हैं ये सारे अब आते हैं यहां पे
आर दे ऑल सीनियर्स ऑफ एसओसी लेवल वन टू
थ्री यस बिल्कुल सही वो सीनियर रोल पे आते
हैं। जी हां L1 L2 L3 के सीनियर रोल पे ही
आते हैं। सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स यू कैन से
L3 के
लाइक लेवल पे यू कैन से बट ऑलमोस्ट हां वो
सीनियर ही होते हैं क्योंकि वो उस टूल पे
बेसिकली दोनों का फंक्शनैलिटी थोड़ा अलग हो
जाता है। वो उस टूल पे काम करते हैं। ठीक
है? राइट आई होप यू गॉट इट नाउ या अब आते
हैं डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर सिक्योरिटी रूल्स
आर द लॉजिक बिल्ट बिहाइंड द सिक्योरिटी
सॉलशंस टू डिटेक्ट हार्मफुल एक्टिविटी अब
जो ये जो सिक्योरिटी टूल्स हैं ये कैसे
डिटेक्ट कर रही हैं अटैक को उसके पीछे कुछ
लॉजिक होगा कुछ एक टेक्नोलॉजी कुछ एक
साइंस होगी मान के चलो कोई ना कोई लॉजिक
तो होता है कि अगर ऐसा हो तो इसको डिटेक्ट
करो है ना जैसे एंटीवायरस वर्क करती है कि
अगर सिग्नेचर नहीं मिसमैच हो रही हो हमारे
डेटाबेस इंजन से तो इसको वायरस बोल दो।
अगर सिग्नेचर मलेशियस हो उसको वायरस बोल
दो। सिग्नेचर ना हो उसको सस्पिशियस
कैटेगरी में डाल दो। ऐसा होता है। उसी
तरीके से जो ये टूल्स हैं ये अलर्ट्स जैसे
देती है ना जिस तरीके से वो एक रूल्स पे
देती हैं। सेट ऑफ रूल्स पे। तो वो जो सिक
रूल्स के लॉजिक होते हैं तो लेवल टू एंड
लेवल थ्री एनालिस्ट उन लॉजिक्स को रूल्स
को तैयार करते हैं, क्रिएट करते हैं।
व्हाइल द एसोस एसओसी टीम कैन समटाइ्स
आल्सो यूटिलाइज द डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर रोल
इंडिपेंडेंटली फॉर दिस रिस्पांसिबिलिटी।
अब ये कंपनीज़ टू कंपनीज़ डिपेंड करती है।
कोई मान लो छोटी कंपनी है तो वो अगर उसके
पास L1, L2, L3 के हैं ऑलरेडी बंदे हैं
L2, के, L3 के तो हो सकता है वो डिटेक्शन
इंजीनियर अपॉइंट नहीं करेगा क्योंकि उसको
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। एंड बड़ी-बड़ी
कंपनीज़ हैं बहुत बड़ा इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है
तो वो डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स का एक अलग
सेगमेंट रखती है। उनके एक अलग पोस्टिंग
होता है डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर का। वो उसको
सेपरेटली इसी काम के लिए बस रखेंगी कि जो
भी सिक्योरिटी रूल्स है। ठीक है? उनके जो
लॉजिक है जो भी लॉजिक है उनको क्रिएट करना
उनको देखना कि वह लॉजिक सही से काम कर रहे
हैं ना उसमें कोई किसी भी तरह का कोई
मेलिसिस एक्टिविटी तो नहीं है किसी भी तरह
की कोई छेड़खानी तो नहीं है सही से
डिप्लॉय तो हुए हैं वो काम करने के लिए ये
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर रखती हैं। अब ये
डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर्स जो हैं ये जरूरी नहीं
है सारे कंपनी में हो बट होती भी हैं बड़ी
कंपनीज़ में। अदरवाइज लेवल जो टू है एंड
लेवल थ्री वाले जो एनालिस्ट है वही ये काम
भी कर लेते हैं। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? अब देखो एंड लास्ट में आते हैं
एसओसी मैनेजर। एसओसी मैनेजर। अब देखो इस
पूरी ट्रेनिंग में आपका प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट
भी होगा। सब कुछ होगा। ए टू जेड चीजें
होंगी। बट वो मैं तभी आपके लिए लेकर आ
पाऊंगा। तभी मैं आपको करा पाऊंगा जब आपकी
तरफ से सिंसियरनेस होगी। मैं नहीं चाहता
कि इस ट्रेनिंग को आप बाकी ट्रेनिंग की
तरह लें। एंड अगर आप अपने फैमिली में आप
अपने घर पर पेरेंट्स को भी जब आप बताएंगे
कि ऐसी ट्रेनिंग जो है वो हो रही है जिससे
मुझे स्किल मिल रही है तो मैं आपको गारंटी
दे रहा हूं कि आपके घर वाले सारा काम
बोलेंगे छोड़ के इस ट्रेनिंग को करने को
मैं इस बात की गारंटी दे रहा हूं वो तो
आपकी अपनी मर्जी होती है कि चलो
रिकॉर्डिंग ये कर लेते हैं वो कर लेते हैं
बट जो लाइव में मजा है वो आपको कभी भी मजा
नहीं आने वाला रिकॉर्डिंग में मैं लिख के
आपको देता हूं इस बात की कुछ लोग कर लेते
होंगे रिकॉर्डिंग में बट लाइव में जो मजा
है जो इंटरेक्शन है वो कभी नहीं आएगा।
बस दैट्स इट। अब है एसओसी मैनेजर। एसओसी
मैनेजर क्या होता है भाई? यह कौन सा
प्राणी है? एसओसी मैनेजर मैनेजेस द
प्रोसेस द एसओसी टीम फॉलोज़ एंड प्रोवाइड
सपोर्ट। द एसोसी मैनेजर आल्सो रिमेंस इन
कांटेक्ट वि द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन सीआईएसओ चीफ
इनेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर टू प्रोवाइड हिम द
अपडेट्स। अब एसओसी मैनेजर जो है वो बंदा
है। मैनेजर वाला बंदा है। ठीक है? जैसे
मैनेजर वाले बंदे होते हैं ना। हां भाई सब
ठीक है। काम सब सही चल रहा है ना? हां।
हां L1 L2 L3 ठीक है इंजीनियर ठीक है
अच्छा ठीक है सब सही किया ना डिप्लॉयमेंट
अलर्ट वलट देख रहे हो सब ज्यादा कुछ तो
नहीं अलर्ट हो रहा है ऐसे ही बैठे-बैठे
आराम से इधर-उधर करेगा और डायरेक्शन देगा
क्या अपडेट है आप बताना उधर उसको पता पता
तो होता ही है लेकिन कोर लेवल पे रूट लेवल
पे बेचारा L1 L2 A3 दिमाग खराब कर रहे हैं
अपना इंजीनियर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर दिनभर
लगे पड़े हैं L1 और इधर है मैनेजर हेलो L1
L1 हां सही है। ठीक है। अरे नहीं हुआ। अरे
यार डिप्लॉय करो यार। इतना टाइम लगता है
क्या? मुझे सीआईएसओ को रिपोर्ट करनी है।
सो सीआईएसओ को मैं क्या जवाब दूंगा? बस अब
L1 L2 L3 की हालत खराब है। वो बेचारे लगे
पड़े हैं अलग-अलग अलर्ट्स को डॉक्यूमेंट
करने में, वो करने में सब ये चीज़ है। तो
ये चीजें एसओसी मैनेजर करता है। अब
क्योंकि इस बच्चे को भी ना रिपोर्ट करनी
है अपने से बड़े बच्चे को। सीआईएसओ चीफ
इनफेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर। यह बहुत बड़ा रोल
होता है भाई सीआईएसओ। इट्स अ वेरी वेरी
बिग रोल इन अ कंपनी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर तो सीआईएसओ को बताना है
भाई
अब सीआईएसओ बोलेगा अरे मैनेजर क्या हुआ सर
सर सर सर अब बताता हूं सर बताता हूं सर अब
वो इन लोगों की बैंड बजाएगा इधर से
रिपोर्ट नहीं गई तो सीआईएसओ इसकी बैंड बजा
देगा तो एक हरार्की में बैंड सबकी बज रही
है सीआईएसओ को कौन बैंड बजाएगा सीआईएसओ जो
होंगे ना ऊपर वाला उसको सीईओ बैंड बैंड
बजाएगा उसकी जो कंपनी का सीईओ है या
डायरेक्टर है जो उसके जिसके अंदर वो काम
कर रहा है क्योंकि सीआईएसओ सीटीओ ये लगभग
सेम लेवल पे ऑपरेट कर रहे होते हैं ये चीज
है तो ये जब कंपनी में काम करोगे तो ऐसे
करने से नहीं होगा रिप्लाई करना होता है
रिस्पांस देना पड़ता है दिखाना पड़ता है
चीजों को कि क्या कर रहे हो तुम एक्सक्टली
पैसे ले रहे हो ना भाई तो कुछ तो करके
दिखाओगे ऐसे थोड़ी ना काम चलेगा बस ये है
समझे तो ये हैं एसओसी मैनेजर हमारे एंड
फिर हमारे सीआईएसओ आ जाते हैं
अब आते हैं प्रोसेस पे। पीपल को आपने देख
लिया। पीपल हमारे गए। पीपल इज गॉन। नाउ
इट्स टाइम टू प्रोसेस। कि प्रोसेस क्या
है? अब इस प्रोसेस में सबसे पहला काम है
अलर्ट ट्रैक का। अलर्ट को ट्रैक करना। द
अलर्ट। अरे भैया
हम
द अलर्ट ट्रायग इज़ द बेसिस ऑफ़ एसो
एसोसिएटिव द फर्स्ट रिस्पांस टू एनी अलर्ट
इज़ टू परफॉर्म द ट्रायग। अब ट्रायग क्या
है? ट्रायग क्या होता है? मैं आपको बताता
हूं। अब जैसे कोई एक अलर्ट आया मैलवेयर
डिटेक्टेड ऑन होस्ट जॉर्ज पीसी। मान लो एक
अलर्ट आया यह कि मैल डिटेक्ट हुई है।
ठीक है? एट हायर पोजीशन इन एसओसी एनीवन
कैन गो डायरेक्टली एज फ्रेशर्स। अरे
फ्रेशर्स कभी भी हायर पोजीशन पे नहीं जाते
हैं। ये गलत ये गलत ही बात मत बताओ भाई।
एसओसी मैनेजर तब कैसे बन सकते हैं? हां,
मैनेजर बनना है। देखो कौन है भाई? राकेश
कुमार शाह। देखो एसओसी मैनेजर बनना है
इनको एज अ फ्रेशर सीधा एसओसी मैनेजर बनना
है। देखो यहां पे पीतांबर इज़ ऑलरेडी देयर।
एसओसी मैनेजर। पीतांबर इज़ ऑलरेडी अह इज़ अ
एसओसी मैनेजर एंड पीतांबर इज़ ऑलरेडी अह वन
ऑफ़ आवर वेरी गुड स्टूडेंट ऑफ़ आवर शायद पेड
ट्रेनिंग के ये स्टूडेंट हैं। आई थिंक पी
पीतांबर आई एम राइट। जहां तक मैं रिकॉल कर
पा रहा हूं। आप हमारे किसी ना किसी
ट्रेनिंग में तो हैं। मुझे नाम थोड़ा
रिकॉल हो रहा है क्योंकि मैं एक बार नाम
देखता हूं तो रिकॉल हो जाता है। सो इफ यू
वांट टू कंफर्म प्लीज कंफर्म सो दैट कि आप
किस ट्रेनिंग में अभी हैं फिलहाल हमारे
साथ पीतांबर एंड
एसओसी मैनेजर बनना है इनको तो मैंने सोचा
कि आप ऑलरेडी मैनेजर हैं तो
आपसे ही पूछ लिया जाए।
सीआईएसओ कैसे बनना है? अरे भाई सीएसओ बनना
है। देखो सीएसओ बनना है।
एसओसी प्लस बग बाउंट किस जॉब के लिए
अप्लाई करें? अरे टेंशन मत लो यार मैं
बताऊंगा। जीरो टेक मैं बताऊंगा। बार-बार
आप एक ही मैसेज को मत करो प्लीज। इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट।
अह इफ देयर इज़ पीतांबर। यू कैन लेट मी नो।
अह क्योंकि मुझे जहां तक याद आ रहा है
हल्का-फुल्का कि यू आर ऑलरेडी इन पेड
ट्रेनिंग।
आई डोंट नो आई डोंट आई डोंट थिंक
थैंक यू सर फॉर रियली वैल्यूुएबल कंटेंट
योर वेलकम साइबर गर्ल टॉक्स यू आर वेरी
वेलकम यस डोंट स्पैम प्लीज इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट
ओके
सो आपको अगर डायरेक्ट भैया आपको डायरेक्ट
अगर मैनेजर एसोसिट मैनेजर बनना है तो ये
इतना आसान नहीं है। यू विल नीड सम अह
इयर्स ऑफ़ एक्सपीरियंस। एंड ऐज़ हियर देयर
देयर देयर वाज़ वन ऑफ़ द स्टूडेंट ऑफ़ आर्स
पीतांबर एंड ही इज़ आल्सो एसओसी मैनेजर। अह
इनके पास 15 साल का एक्सपीरियंस है। तो
मैं यह नहीं बोलूंगा कि आपको भी 15 साल ही
लगेंगे। यू कैन गेट एट दैट प्लेस इन विद
इन 10 इयर्स और फाइव इयर्स आल्सो।
डिपेंडिंग ऑन योर परफ़ॉर्मेंस एंड योर अह
लाइक डडीिकेशन फॉर अह फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर
रोल। यह आपके डेडिकेशन पे डिपेंड करता है।
याद रखिएगा
बता दिया मैंने आपको राकेश एसओसी मैनेजर
बनने के लिए मैंने मिनिमम आपको 10 10 साल
के आसपास मान लो 10 या 5 साल 5 साल मान लो
5 साल से 10 साल के बीच का टाइम 5 साल से
10 साल के बीच का टाइमलाइन लेके चल लो ठीक
है गॉट इट
ओके पीतांबर इज़ इन वीएपीटी ओके तो हमारे
डीसीएपीटी वीएपीटी में है वो तभी मुझे लग
रहा था कि
चलो अब अगर एज अ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट जब
प्रोसेस वाली आप काम शुरू करते हैं। देखो
मैंने पहले आपको बताया था क्या तीन चीजें
बताई थी मैंने आपको पीपल प्रोसेस एंड
टेक्नोलॉजी जिसमें कि हमने पीपल को डिस्कस
कर लिया है। पी प्रोसेस पे हम आ चुके हैं।
अब प्रोसेस में अलर्ट ट्रैक सबसे पहला
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है। अलर्ट ट्रैक
में मान लो एक अलर्ट आता है। मैलवेयर
डिटेक्टेड ऑन होस्ट दिस पर्टिकुलर होस्ट।
ये आपके पास अलर्ट आया। आपके जो भी टूल्स
हैं जो भी आप सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन यूज़ कर
रहे हैं व्हाटएवर सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन उस
पे हटा लिया। अब इसमें आपको पांच डब्ल्यू
का आंसर देना होता है या पांच डब्ल्यू के
आंसर को मन में इमेजिन करना है कि देयर आर
फाइव डब्ल्यूस व्हिच आई शुड बी आंसरिंग और
आई शुड आंसर देन ओनली यू आर कंप्लीटिंग
दिस पर्टिकुलर ट्रैक प्रोसेस। [हंसी]
क्या है वो पांच डब्लू? तो पांच डब्ल्यू
को दिखाने के लिए मैं आपको फिर से इसको
थोड़ा सा ऐसे करना पड़ेगा डिस्कार।
ये जो इमेज है पहले मैं इसको थोड़ा इधर
करता हूं। हां जी। अब आई थिंक ये विज़िबल
हो जाना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से। यस। दो फाइव
डब्लूस आर ये जो आपको ये एक इमेज दिख रही
है। इसमें आपको ये इमेज दिख रही है। हु
व्हाट? वाई, वेयर, व्हेन। पांच ये
डब्ल्यूस हैं। सिंपल। हु, व्हाट? वाई,
वेयर, व्हेन। ये पांच डब्ल्यूस का आपको
ध्यान रखना है। अब ये पांच डब्ल्यूस
एग्जैक्टली क्या है? उस पे भी हम आएंगे।
डोंट वरी अबाउट दैट। व्हाट दीज़ फाइव
डब्ल्यूस आर।
पहला डब्ल्यू व्हाट? इस पे आते हैं। अ
मलिशस फाइल वाज़ डिटेक्टेड ऑन वन ऑफ़ द
होस्ट इनसाइड द ऑ्गेनाइजेशन नेटवर्क।
व्हाट? क्या? तो एक मलिशस फाइल डिटेक्ट
हुई है। ठीक है? व्हेन कब हुई थी? द फाइल
वाज़ डिटेक्टेड एट 12:30
या 1320
ऑन सम पर्टिकुलर डेट। ये आपको आंसर मिल
गया। कब हुई थी? वेयर द फाइल वाज़
डिटेक्टेड। यहां पर मैं यह ले लेता हूं। द
फाइल वाज़ डिटेक्टेड इन द डायरेक्टरी ऑफ द
होस्ट। जॉर्ज पीसी कब हुई थी? कहां हुई
थी? मतलब वेयर हुई थी? तो डायरेक्टरी ऑफ़ द
होस्ट। हु द फाइल वाज़ डिटेक्टेड फॉर यूजर
जॉर्ज।
हु
किसके पास ये फाइल डिटेक्शन थी। हु तो
जॉर्ज के पास जो यूजर है। एंड व्हाई आफ्टर
द इन्वेस्टिगेशन व्हाई? इट वाज़ फाउंड दैट
द फाइल वाज़ डाउनलोडेड फ्रॉम अ पाइरेटेड
सॉफ्टवेयर सेलिंग वेबसाइट। कि यह फाइल
डाउनलोड क्यों हो गई थी भाई? व्हाई? द
इन्वेस्टिगेशन विद द यूजर रिवील्ड दैट दे
डाउनलोडेड द फाइल एज़ दे वांटेड टू यूज़ अ
सॉफ्टवेयर फॉर फ्री। तो आप किसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के एक एंप्लई ने क्या किया?
एक क्या क्या किया? किसी एंप्लई ने इधर
ध्यान देना है। सभी को इधर ध्यान देना है
प्लीज़। एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के एक एंप्लई ने
एक परेट साइट से सॉफ्टवेयर डाउनलोड करी।
क्यों करी? ताकि उसको फ्री में यूज़ कर
सके। बट उसके अंदर में क्या था भैया? एक
मैलवेयर था एंड यही आपके वाई को आंसर करता
है। सो दीज़ आर द फाइव डब्लूस दैट यू हैव
टू आंसर। दैट्स इट। इधर फोकस कीजिए आप
लोग। आप लोग मेरी बात तो कम से कम मानिए
कि इधर फोकस करना है आपको। जब मैं बता रहा
हूं कुछ तो फोकस कीजिए। नहीं बता रहा हूं
तो चैट में आप आ सकते हैं। नो इश्यूज। ठीक
है?
अगर यह फाइव डब्लूस का आप आंसर कर पा रहे
हैं, कर रहे हैं, देन यू आर डूइंग
सक्सेसफुल ट्रैक। अलर्ट ट्रैक दैट्स इट।
यह पहला प्रोसेस का पहला पार्ट अलर्ट
ट्रैक प्रोसेस का दूसरा पार्ट वो है
रिपोर्टिंग। ये इसी का दूसरा पार्ट है
रिपोर्टिंग। रिपोर्टिंग में क्या होती है?
द डिटेक्टेड हार्मफुल अलर्ट्स नीड्स टू बी
एस्केलेटेड टू हायर लेवल एनालिसिस फॉर
टाइमली रिस्पांस एंड रेोल्यूशन। अगर कोई
हार्मफुल अलर्ट है एंड वो थोड़ी थोड़ी
कॉम्प्लेक्स है। कॉम्प्लेक्स अलर्ट है तो
हाई सीवियरिटी के अलर्ट है। तो इसको जो है
एस्केलेट करना जरूरी है। दीज़ अलर्ट्स आर
एस्केलेटेड एज टिकट्स। इनको एस्केलेट
टिकट्स के थ्रू किया जाता है। टिकटिंग
सॉफ्टवेयर्स आते हैं उसके थ्रू किया जाता
है। एंड असाइन टू द रिलेवेंट पीपल। जो भी
उसके जैसे आप L2, L3 जिसको भी आप कर रहे
हैं बेसिकली एस्केलेट कर रहे हैं उनको
असाइन किया जाता है। दैट्स इट।
द रिपोर्ट शुड डिस्कस ऑल द फाइव डब्ल्यूस
अलोंग विद अ थरो एनालिसिस एंड स्क्रीनशॉट
शुड बी यूज्ड एज एविडेंस ऑफ द एक्टिविटी।
अब इसी डॉक्यूमेंटेशन में रिपोर्ट में
आपके वो पांच डब्ल्यूस का आंसर होना चाहिए
जो मैंने आपको बताया। पांच डब्ल्यूस के
आंसर अगर होंगे तो रिपोर्ट परफेक्ट है
जिसमें कि हु व्हाट वाई वेयर व्हेन सिंपल
यह आपको याद कर लेना है हु व्हाट व्हाई
वेयर व्हेन पांच डब्ल्यूस हु व्हाट व्हाई
वेयर व्हेन सिंपल अगर है तो आपका
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन बिल्कुल सही है
बिल्कुल सही है हां तो इनिशियल लेवल की
इन्वेस्टिगेशन तो करेगा ना एल1 स्टिक्ड
ऑफिशियल इनिशियल ले लेवल का इनिशियल लेवल
का इंस्पेक्शन तो करेगा ना L1 तो उसको Y
का पता चल जाएगा कि हां भैया ये डाउनलोड
हुई थी उसी वजह से मैलवेयर आई है। अब क्या
मैलवेयर है क्या प्रोसेस है किस तरीके से
करना है वो आगे एस्केलेट हो के पता चलेगा
राइट समझ में आ गया स्टिक्ड
आई थिंक यू गॉट द पॉइंट राइट राहुल प्लीज
डोंट स्पैम ब्रदर अदरवाई है टू पुट इन द
आपको फिर लगर टाइम आउट के लिए पुट करना
पड़ेगा अभी तो एक मिनट के लिए किया है
चलिए अब आते हैं लास्ट में इंसिडेंट
रिस्पांस एंड फॉरेंसिक्स। समटाइ्स द
रिपोर्टेड डिटेक्शंस पॉइंट्स टू हली
मलिशियस एक्टिविटी दैट आर क्रिटिकल दैट जो
बहुत क्रिटिकल होते हैं। इधर ध्यान दे लो
चैट से इधर हट के। कभी-कभी होता है ऐसे जो
डिटेक्शंस होते हैं वो हाईली क्रिटिकल
होते हैं। इन दीज़ सिनेरियोज़ हाई लेवल
टीम्स इनिशिएट एन इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस। इस
केस में एक इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस जो है वो
इनिशिएट की जाती है। अ फ्यू टाइम्स अ
डिटेल्ड फॉरेंसिक एक्टिविटी आल्सो नीड्स
टू बी परफॉर्म्ड दिस फॉरेंसिक एक्टिविटी
एम्स टू डिटरमाइन द इंसिडेंस रूट कॉज।
कभी-कभी फॉरेंसिक्स एक्टिविटी फॉरेंसिक्स
अ एक्टिविटी की रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ जाती है।
फॉरेंसिक्स जो है इन्वेस्टिगेशन की
रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ जाती है ताकि एग्जैक्ट
रूट कॉज पता चल जाए जो कि नॉर्मली पता
नहीं चल पा रही है। तो कभी-कभी ये करना
पड़ जाता है। जिसकी वजह से ये स्टेप आती
है इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस एंड फॉरेंसिक्स। दीज़
आर द स्टेप्स। तो ये पूरी प्रोसेस की
स्टेप्स पहला अलर्ट ट्राय का है। दूसरा
रिपोर्टिंग का होता है। एंड तीसरा
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस एंड फॉरेंसिक्स का होता
है। अब लास्ट में आते हैं टेक्नोलॉजिया।
टेक्नोलॉजिया पे आते हैं जो कि सबसे
ज्यादा खतरनाक सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
एंड सबसे ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। विदाउट
सर्टिफिकेट वी कैन वी कैन गेट द जॉब।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल भाई
विदाउट सर्टिफिकेट भी आप जॉब ले सकते हैं।
मैं आपको बताऊंगा सब तरीका। आप ये
ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट करो। मैं बता रहा हूं ना
आप सब के सब इस ट्रेनिंग को कंप्लीट करो।
मैं गारंटी देता हूं अगर आप सिंसियरली
कंप्लीट करते हैं ना तो आप में से
मैक्सिमम लोगों के जॉब होने के चांसेस
होंगे इफ यू आर एलिजिबिल। अब एलिजिबल का
मतलब ये है कि अगर कोई कंपनी ये बोल दे कि
मेरे को बीटेक वाले ही चाहिए और आप बीटेक
नहीं है तो फिर उसमें मैं क्या कर पाऊंगा?
राइट? तो आप स्किल पे फोकस कीजिए। आप
नॉलेज लेने की कोशिश कीजिए। ये जो एसओसी
का है पूरा नॉलेज और स्किल ये सिर्फ एसओसी
में यूज़ नहीं होने वाला है। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का पार्ट है ये। ये साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन ही है आपका जो आपको एक
घुसाएगा अंदर एंट्री दिलाएगा। एंड अगर कोई
यहां पे एसओसी रिलेटेड कोई भी जॉब करते
हैं, प्रोफेशनल हैं तो प्लीज मुझे बताइए
एंड करेक्ट मी इफ आई एम रोंग। एंड आल्सो
लेट अदर्स नो इफ दिस इज़ राइट। कि आप
एंट्री लेवल एंड जॉब के लिए और साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में घुसने के लिए एसओसी का यूज
बहुत अच्छे से कर सकते हैं।
एंड कई लोग ने ऐसे ही जॉब करी है। बट उनका
मन आगे अंदर में ही उनका फिर लग गया है कि
हां भाई नहीं मेरे लिए ये सही है रोल में
मेरे को इसी फील्ड में रहना है। इसी में
फिर आगे अपने रोल्स को अह जो है वह
प्रमोशन लेने हैं। मैनेजर एंड डायरेक्टर
तक जाना है। तो वो लोग उसी में रह चुके
हैं। एसओसी के फील्ड में ही है। तो इफ यू
आर समवन लाइक यहां पे प्रोफेशनल कोई है?
एसओसी प्रोफेशनल्स हैं कोई यहां पे? एक तो
मैनेजर थे यहां पे बट और भी कोई है? प्लीज
लेट मी नो। प्लीज लेट मी नो।
प्रवीण कुमार थैंक यू ब्रदर। कुछ ज्यादा
यह तो कुछ ज्यादा ही तारीफ हो गई। बट थैंक
यू वेरी मच। एनीवन एनआईएल एनआईएल 5G ओके
यू आर आप अपना रोल बता दीजिए। आप किस रोल
पे हैं एसओसी के अंदर? प्लीज बता दीजिए।
सर आई ऑलरेडी नो बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स ऑफ़ मेनी
वेब वनेबिलिटीज़। अभी वेब वनेबिलिटीज़ के
करने के लिए नहीं आ रहा है। लैब्स बग
बाउंड के लिए अभी बाद में बात करेंगे बग
बाउंडिंग का। इसके लिए बताओ। कोई है यहां
पे एसओसी जो ऑलरेडी एसओसी एनालिस्ट है या
एसओसी रोल में काम करते हैं।
आई डोंट थिंक सो आई डोंट थिंक सो ठीक है
आई एम अ थ्रेट मॉडलिंग स्टूडेंट आई एम
एसओसी एल1 नाउ 1.5 इयर्स करियर गैप क्या
बात है
थैंक यू आरव तारीफ के लिए यू आर गुड
ओके यहां पे अ गुरु किरण नागर करके के हैं
शायद। आई एम सॉरी अगर नाम गलत कुछ बोला हो
मैंने तो। बट
ही इज़ एल वन 1.5 इयर्स का गैप है। तो तो
मैं मैनेजर नहीं हूं भाई। मैं मैनेजर नहीं
हूं। अब आते हैं यहां पे टेक्नोलॉजी के
ऊपर। टेक्नोलॉजी। आई एम नाउ वी आर कमिंग
ऑन द टेक्नोलॉजी पार्ट।
अब देखो हैविंग द राइट पीपल एंड
प्रोसेससेस इन प्लेस वुड नेवर बी इनफ
विदाउट सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस फॉर डिटेक्शन
एंड रिस्पांस। अब ये पीपल प्रोसेससेस का
क्या मतलब है? अगर आपके पास एक बढ़िया
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन नहीं है, ऑटोमेटेड
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन नहीं है। एआई इनेबल
सिक्योर अब तो सारे एसआईएम टूल्स जो हैं
एआई इनेबल्ड हो चुके हैं। एआई का भी यूज़
हो रहा है। एआई एजेंट्स का यूज़ हो रहा है।
तो अगर आप एआई वगैरह का भी नॉलेज रखते हैं
तो अच्छी बात है। एंड एंड मैं कोशिश
करूंगा कि आपके इस एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल वन
की ट्रेनिंग में एआई को भी घुसा दूं आगे
चलके। एंड उसका भी रोल समझाऊं कि कैसे?
क्योंकि ताकि आपको रिप्लेस ना किया जा
सके। अगर आपकी जॉब हो भी जाए तो किसी एआई
वाले बंदे से रिप्लेस ना किया जा सके
क्योंकि जॉब किसी की नहीं जाती है। जॉब
उसी की जाएगी जो एआई से कनेक्टेड नहीं है।
जो एआई को नहीं जानता। एआई से फमिलियर
नहीं है। बाकी सब रोल्स सब जगह अपना काम
करेंगे। ठीक है?
ओके। दिस सेशन हेल्प मी टू रिकॉल
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स। थैंक यू ब्रदर। द
टेक्नोलॉजी पोर्शन इन द एसओसी पिलर्स
रेफर्स टू द सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस।
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस के बिना ये पीपल एंड
प्रोसेससेस कुछ भी नहीं है। वो जो
सॉफ्टवेयर जो ऑटोमेशन सॉफ्टवेयर जो
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस आप यूज़ करोगे उसके बिना
अभी फिलहाल ये पीपल प्रोसेससेस नहीं है।
क्योंकि इतने सारे अलर्ट्स इतनी सारी
चीजें होती हैं कि मैनुअली इंटरवेन करना,
मैनुअली प्रोसेस करना, मैनुअली सब चीजों
को देखना एंड एनालाइज करना इज़ नियर टू
इंपॉसिबल। दैट्स व्हाई वी नीड सिक्योरिटी
सॉलशंस। एंड यहां पे आते हैं टूल्स की बात
करते हैं। अब यहां पे कुछ टूल्स हैं जिनके
बारे में हम बात करेंगे जिसमें कि द
फर्स्ट वन इज जो एक सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन
है एसआईएम जिसको कि आप बोलते हैं
सिक्योरिटी इनेशन एंड इवेंट मैनेजमेंट।
ये एक पॉपुलर टूल है जो कि यूज किया जाता
है इन ऑलमोस्ट एव्री एसोसिएट एनवायरमेंट।
इसका काम क्या होता है? लॉग्स को कलेक्ट
करना फ्रॉम डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस एंड यहां पे जितने भी लॉग के
सोर्सेस हैं उन सबको क्वरी करके एंड उन
लॉग्स को कलेक्ट करना ये इसका मेन
प्राइमरी मोटो होता है एसआईएम टूल्स का।
अब इसी एसआईएम टूल्स जो हैं टूल्स के अंदर
में इसी एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन के अंदर में
डिटेक्शन रूल्स क्फिगर किए जाते हैं।
डिटेक्शन रूल्स आर कॉन्फ़िगर
व्हिच कंटेन लॉजिक टू आइडेंटिफाई सस्पिस
एक्टिविटी जिसके अंदर लॉजिक होता है। याद
है लॉजिक लॉजिक की मैंने बात की थी। याद
होगा अगर आपको थोड़े टाइम पहले तो लॉजिक
की जब मैंने बात करी थी तो यह डिटेक्शन
इंजीनियर की यहां पे बात हुई सिक्योरिटी
रूल्स आर द लॉजिक बिल्ड बिहाइंड द
सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस जिसको L2 L3 जो है वो
बनाते हैं कॉफ़िगर करते हैं बट उसके लिए
कभी-कभी डिटेक्शन इंजीनियर अलग से भी होते
हैं। उसी लॉजिक की यहां पे बात कर रहा
हूं। तो डिटेक्शन रूल्स आर कॉन्फ़िगर्ड इन
एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन। इसमें डिटेक्शन रूल्स जो
है वो कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड होते हैं। व्हिच कंटेन
लॉजिक टू आइडेंटिफाई सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी।
जो भी सस्पेश एक्टिविटी है उसको
आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए रूल्स होते हैं। द
एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन प्रोवाइड्स अस विद द
डिटेक्शंस आफ्टर कोरिलेटिंग देम विद
मल्टीपल लॉग सोर्सेस एंड अलर्ट्स अस इन
केस ऑफ ए मैच विद एनी ऑफ़ द रूल्स। अब इनका
काम क्या होता है? इनका काम होता है कि यह
मल्टीपल लॉग्स
को मॉनिटर करते हैं। एंड उन लॉग्स में
मॉनिटरिंग के टाइम ये अलग-अलग रूल्स के
अकॉर्डिंग अगर कोई रूल्स से आपकी उस लॉग
में जब ये मॉनिटर कर रहे होते हैं वो किसी
रूल से मैच करता है वो तो आपको अलर्ट करते
हैं। ठीक है? अब जैसे एक रूल है कि ओनली
अलऊ इंटरनल आईपीस टू एक्सेस दिस पर्टिकुलर
रिसोर्स या स्लैश
बैकअप ये डायरेक्टरी इस स्लैश बैकअप या
स्लैश एडमिन डॉट बैकअप ये एक फाइल है।
इसको एक्सेस करने का एक रूल ये है कि ओनली
इंटरनल आईपीस आर अलाउड।
अब अगर कोई लॉग में एक्सटर्नल आईपी से
किसी तरह का रिक्वेस्ट या किसी तरह का
पिंग पैकेट आ रहा है या किसी तरह की
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है तो उसको जब उसको तो
लॉग कर लेगा हमारा हमारा जो लॉग है उसमें
ये दिखेगा लॉग सोर्सेस जो भी होंगे जो भी
नेटवर्क लॉग्स होंगे अब ये मैच करेंगे जो
आपके रूल्स बने रूल्स में क्या था ओनली
इंटरनल आईपीस आर अलाउड जैसे ही एक्सटर्नल
आईपी आएगी लॉग में ये तुरंत अलर्ट एक फायर
कर देगा हमारा जो एसआईएम सिक्योरिटी
सॉल्यूशन है और बोलेगा मलिशियस और
इंट्रूडर डिटेक्टेड इंट्रूडर डिटेक्टेड या
इंट्रूडर ट्राइंग टू गेट इनसाइड इंटू द
नेटवर्क। इंट्रूडर डिटेक्टेड का एक अलर्ट
आ जाएगा। तो इस तरीके से ये काम होता है।
योर वे ऑफ़ टीचिंग इज़ अमेजिंग। थैंक यू
ब्रदर। थैंक यू।
देखो बहुत ज्यादा मैसेज एक ही मैसेज को मत
कॉपी पेस्ट करो। मुझे पता है यार कि तुम
चैट में एक मैसेज को कॉपी पेस्ट करके
फटाफट डाल सकते हो। ये करोगे तो टाइम आउट
में मुझे डालना पड़ जाता है। फिर आप मैसेज
नहीं कर पाओगे। तो ऐसा मत करो। एक बार करो
दो बार करो। दैट्स इट। सर वेदर वी विल बी
लर्निंग द क्रिएशन ऑफ़ रूल्स एज इट्स पार्ट
ऑफ़ सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर। तो सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर का पार्ट है। तो तुम पढ़ के भी
क्या करोगे? लेकिन तुम्हें आईडिया मैं
दूंगा। टेंशन मत लो।
आईडिया मैं दूंगा। आईडिया मैं तुम्हें
बढ़िया-बढ़िया दूंगा। एसओसी L1 मैं पढ़ा रहा
हूं। बट मैं आपको आइडियाज L2, L3
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर तक के दे दूंगा। अब
सीआईएसओ का तो ऑब्वियसली कोई काम नहीं
आएगा आपके बट टेक वाला सब दे दूंगा मैं।
पहले L1 को फुल्ली कंप्लीट करते हैं अच्छे
से। बहुत अच्छे से करते हैं। ठीक है?
अब यहां देखो मॉडर्न एसआईएम सॉलशंस सरपास
दिस रूल बेस्ड डिटेक्शन एनालिसिस।
प्रोवाइडिंग अस विद यूजर बिहेवियर
एनालिटिक्स एंड थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस
कैपेबिलिटी। मशीन लर्निंग एल्गोरिदम
सपोर्ट्स दिस टू एनहांस द डिटेक्शन
कैपेबिलिटीज। आ गई ना बात यहां पे
एआई की। अब मॉडर्न एसआईएम जो टूल्स हैं ये
रूल बेस्ड डिटेक्शन एनालिसिस को ज्यादा
तवज्जो नहीं देते। ज्यादा भाव नहीं देते।
अब ये क्या कर रहे हैं? ये अब यूजर
बिहेवियर एनालिटिक्स के ऊपर ज्यादा फोकस्ड
है।
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस के ऊपर ज्यादा फोकस्ड
है। मतलब कि एक ऐसा इंटेलिजेंस सिस्टम एक
ऐसा इंटेलिजेंस सिस्टम क्रिएट करना,
इंटेलिजेंट सिस्टम क्रिएट करना जो यूजर के
बिहेवियर के ऊपर काम करती हो ज्यादातर
रेदर देन जस्ट रूल्स। क्योंकि रूल्स को तो
सरकमेंट किया जा सकता है ना। रूल्स के
इधर-उधर से निकला जा सकता है। रूल्स को
मॉडिफाई मलिशियसली तरीके से इंजेक्ट किया
जा सकता है। बट यूजर बिहेवियर को इंजेक्ट
करना इतना आसान नहीं है। तो आप किस तरीके
से कौन सी चीज एक्सेस कर रहे हो? किस
तरीके से ऑपरेट कर रहे हो? अगर उस पैटर्न
को कोई टूल डिटेक्ट कर रही है एंड उसके
बेसिस पे आपको बता रही है कि भैया ये
मलशियस हो सकता है एक्टर। ये मलेशियस
वेक्टर हो सकता है। ये बहुत बड़ी बात है।
एंड इसमें मशीन लर्निंग का यूज़ किया जा
रहा है। आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस का यूज़
किया जा रहा है। तो हर एसआईएम टूल्स आज के
टाइम में आर्टिफिशियल इंटेलिजेंस से लैश
हो चुके हैं। एमएल से मशीन लर्निंग से लैश
हो चुके हैं। याद रखिएगा ये चीज।
अब आते हैं
एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन ओनली प्रोवाइड्स द
डिटेक्शन कैपेबिलिटीज इन अ एसोसिए
एनवायरमेंट। अब जो एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है यह
डिटेक्शन कैपेबिलिटीज जो है यह प्रोवाइड
करती है एसआईएम एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में याद
रखिएगा जो एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन होती है
डिटेक्शन कैपेबिलिटीज अब यहां पे हम बात
करते हैं टेक्नोलॉजी के अंदर में एक ईडीआर
की व्हाट इज द ईडीआर अब मैं ये चीजें
एक-एक चीजें बता रहा हूं आपको इसलिए गाइस
क्योंकि जब मैं आपको छोटी-छोटी चीजें बता
रहा हूं ना ईडीआर एंड ये सब चीजें अगर
इसकी नॉलेज आपको नहीं है तो यकीन मानो
आपको बाद में कुछ नहीं समझ में आएगा
कुछ भी नहीं समझ में आएगा। नथिंग।
दैट्स इट। अरे देखो ह्यूमन बिहेवियर का
मतलब सिंपल तरीके से समझ लो। अब मान लो
लेट्स सपोज कि कोई इंसाइडर थ्रेट है। कोई
आपका एंप्लई है कंपनी के अंदर में ऐसा या
कोई बाहर का ही है। चलो मैं इंसाइडर की
पहले बात कर लेता हूं। अब इंसाइडर थ्रेट
है कोई। अब वो किसी एक बहुत ही सेंसिटिव
डायरेक्टरी को एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर
रहा है जो उसके
लेवल ऑफ एक्सेस से कई गुना ज्यादा ऊपर की
है। उसके एक्सेस लेवल में है ही नहीं वो।
उसको वो एक्सेस करना ही नहीं। उसके उसके
एक्सेस लेवल से बाहर की चीज है वो। उसको
बट फिर भी ट्राई कर रहा है एक्सेस करने
का। बार-बार रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा है।
बार-बार ट्राई कर रहा है। पासवर्ड गलत आ
रहा है बार-बार। तो ये एक एनालिसिस हो
जाएगी टूल्स की तरफ से। बिहेवियरल जो
एनालिसिस होती है वो हो जाएगी कि व्हाई
दिस पर्टिकुलर आईपी अब वो इंसान को तो
नहीं जानता ना यूजर को जानता है आईपी को
जानता है व्हाई दिस आईपी और दिस यूजर इज़
क्वरिंग अगेन एंड अगेन टू दिस पर्टिकुलर
स्पेसिफिक डायरेक्टरी इवन व्हेन दे आर नॉट
अलाउड टू दे आर नॉट गिवन एक्सेस टू वो
एक्सेस लेवल है ही नहीं उसका तो हो गया
एनालिसिस ये चीज है अब ये लॉजिक भी हो
सकती है बट जब बिहेवियरल एनालिसिस होगी तो
ये ज्यादा इफेक्टिवली काम करेगी गी यह
मल्टीपल ग्रुप ऑफ एंप्लई के ऊपर काम
करेगी। एक साथ में बहुत अच्छे से काम
करेगी। थोड़ी भी इधर-उधर होगी वह अलर्ट
जारी कर देगा। ये पावर होती है। आई होप यू
गॉट।
आई होप आपको समझ में आया होगा। समझ में
आया गाइज़ आपको यहां तक।
यू गॉट इट।
ओके। बहुत बढ़िया। समझ में आ रहा है आपको?
आपको आप लोगों नहीं मुझे पहले आप बताओ यार
तभी मैं आगे बताऊंगा। मुझे आप बताओ कि आप
लोगों को समझ में आ रहा है भाई?
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस।
प्लीज लेट मी नो। बहुत कम लोगों के आंसर आ
रहे हैं। मजा नहीं आ रहा है। आंसर इतने कम
लोगों के क्यों आ रहे हैं? इतने लोग लाइव
लाइव में हैं। अभी 250 लोग हैं। और यार
250 लोग हैं। 300 भी लाइक्स नहीं पहुंचे
यार। आ रहे हैं सबके? यस यस यस यस
यस यस ठीक है गुड गुड गुड बहुत बढ़िया
थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू थैंक यू गाइज़
बहुत अच्छे से आ रहा है ठीक है चलिए
अब आते हैं हमारे एक सबसे खतरनाक टॉपिक पे
पॉइंट पे इडीआर एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड
रिस्पांस ईडीआर जिसको हम बोलते हैं ईडीआर
इट प्रोवाइड द एसोसिएटिव वि डिटेल्ड रियल
टाइम एंड हिस्टोरिकल विजिबिलिटी ऑफ़ द
डिवाइसेस एक्टिविटीज। इडीआर का काम यही
होता है। बहुत लोगों को नहीं समझ में आता
है ईडीआर क्या होता है। नहीं पता था आपको
तो आप जान जाइए कि एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन एंड
रिस्पांस। इसके फुल फॉर्म में इसका
वर्किंग है। एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन
एंड रिस्पांस डिटेक्ट भी करेगा, रिस्पांस
भी करेगा।
एसओसी टीम को ये एक पावरफुल फीचर क्या
देता है? दी एक रियल टाइम डिटेल्ड रियल
टाइम हिस्टोरिकल विजिबिलिटी ऑफ डिवाइसेस
एक्टिविटी जितने भी डिवाइसेस हैं एंडिक
डिवाइसेस हैं एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में उसकी
रियल टाइम जो है ना वो मॉनिटरिंग करके
एक्टिविटीज की डिटेल्स देता है। इट
ऑपरेट्स ऑन द एंड पॉइंट लेवल एंड कैन कैरी
आउट ऑटोमेटेड रिस्पांस। ये एक एंड पॉइंट
लेवल पे काम करता है। एंड पॉइंट लेवल। एंड
पॉइंट लेवल का मतलब है टू द लास्ट ऑफ अ
पर्टिकुलर वर्किंग टेक्नोलॉजी। मतलब मतलब
उसके बाद कुछ है ही नहीं। उसके आगे कुछ
नहीं है। देयर इज़ नथिंग बिय्ड दैट। उस
लेवल पर ये काम करता है। एंड ऑटोमेटेड
रिस्पांससेस भी देता है। ऑटोमेटेड
रिस्पांस इसका काम है ये ऑटोमेटेड
रिस्पांस देना। बिना ऑटोमेटेड रिस्पांस के
क्या क्या फायदा हुआ? श्योर प्रवीण श्योर।
ईडीआर हैज़ एक्सटेंसिव डिटेक्शन
कैपेबिलिटीज़ फॉर एंड पॉइंट्स।
इनके पास एक डिटेक्शन कैपेबिलिटीज होती है
एंड पॉइंट्स पर अलाउंग यू टू इन्वेस्टिगेट
देम इन डिटेल एंड रिसोंड्स विद इन अ फ्यू
क्लिक्स ताकि आप उसको इन्वेस्टिगेट कर
पाएं और कुछ क्लिक्स में ही आप रिसोंड कर
पाएं। ईडीआर की यह पावर होती है। ईडीआर इज़
अ वेरी पावरफुल सॉफ्टवेयर। अब ईडीआर भी
बाईपास होती है। याद रखिएगा जो भी चीजें
यस लाइक एंड यूज़र्स ऋषु बिल्कुल सही। जो
भी चीजें आपको सिक्योर दिखती हैं, सिक्योर
मिलती है, वो सब जो है वो बाईपास भी होती
है उनकी सिक्योरिटी। नथिंग इज कंप्लीट
सिक्योर, नथिंग इज कंप्लीट एनोनिमस। यह
बात हमेशा दिमाग में रखिएगा। सिक्योरिटी
इज काइंड ऑफ इल्यूजन।
यह सच है।
जब तक आप बाईपास नहीं, जब तक आप
अटैक नहीं हुए, तब तक आप सेफ हैं। तब तक
आप सेफ्टी में रहिए, मजे कीजिए। दैट्स इट।
अब यहां पे ईडीआर के बारे में हम डिटेल
में भी पढ़ेंगे। इसका बिल्कुल आप टेंशन मत
लीजिएगा। ईडीआर के ऊपर तो एक एक्स एक
डेडिकेटेड सेशंस होने वाले हैं। यह तो अभी
आपका वार्म अप चल रहा है। वो कहा वो था ना
एक डायलॉग कि जो तुम्हारा टॉर्चर है वो
मेरा वार्म अप है। तो यह तो अभी अभी तो
टॉर्चर शुरू नहीं हुआ है। यह तो वार्म अप
अभी चल रहा है आपके। अभी तो वार्म अप
चलेंगे कुछ टाइम तक। टॉर्चर जब होगा तब तो
मजा आएगा तुमको। तो टॉर्चर मजा आएगा।
एक्सक्टली यह टॉर्चर में मजा आएगा।
एवरीथिंग इज ब्रेकेबल। अब्सोलुटली करेक्ट।
ठीक है? अभी पता चल जाएगा। एंड पॉइंट एंड
पॉइंट में क्या होता है वह पता चल जाएगा।
अभी प्लीज डोंट रिपीट। एंड पॉइंट में क्या
है वो पता चल जाएगा। आप प्लीज बार-बार
रिपीट मत कीजिए। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। ठीक
है?
अब आते हैं फायर वाल पे। अ फायर वाल
फंक्शनंस प्योरली फॉर नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
एंड एक्ट्स एज अ बैरियर बिटवीन योर इंटरनल
एंड एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क्स। ये आप सबको पता
होगा। फायर वाल के बारे में मोस्टली सभी
लोग जानते हैं। एवरीवन नोज़ कि ये क्या
करता है? यह आपके एक्सटर्नल और इंटरनल
लेटर के बीच में एक बैरियर होता है। दैट्स
इट। अब बाहर से कौन सी ट्रैफिक आ रही है
अंदर? अंदर से किधर को जा रही है? इन सब
के ऊपर में इसका कमांड होता है। इन सबके
ऊपर में इसकी निगरानी होती है। बाहर से
कौन सी ट्रैफिक या किस तरह का पैकेट आपके
नेटवर्क को पेनिट्रेट कर रहा है, नेटवर्क
में एंटर कर रहा है। ये फायरवॉल के रूल्स
डिफाइन करते हैं। किसको अलऊ करना है?
किसको अलऊ नहीं करना है? यह सब फायरवल के
रूल्स आपके जो है वो
डिफाइन करते हैं। दैट्स इट। अब जैसे अगर
मैं Windows की बात करूं अगर आपने Windows
में हालांकि सभी को ये चीज पता होनी चाहिए
मुझे लगता है। मैं अगर कंट्रोल पैनल में
Windows firewall को स्टार्ट कर देता हूं।
Windows डिफेंडर फायर है यहां पे। मैं चलो
इसी को स्टार्ट करते हैं। यहां पे तो आप
देखोगे यहां पे Windows Frewl जो होती है
यहां पे। तो यहां पे एक ऑप्शन होता है अलऊ
एन ऐप और फीचर थ्रू Windows डिफेंडर
फायरवल। जब इस पे जाएंगे तो आपको यहां पे
ये रूल्स आपको दिखेंगे। देखो ये आपके
रूल्स हैं टू ऐड और रिमूव पोर्ट्स अलाउड
जो। अब ये अलग-अलग जो है ना एप्स हैं,
अलग-अलग फीचर्स हैं। कौन से फीचर्स को
आपने प्राइवेट नेटवर्क पे या पब्लिक
नेटवर्क पे जो भी आप नेटवर्क यूज़ कर रहे
हो अगर आपका पब्लिक नेटवर्क है तो पब्लिक
वाले सेक्शन को चेक करेंगे। प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क है तो प्राइवेट वाले से नेटवर्क
सेक्शन को चेक करेंगे। तो आपके नेटवर्क से
कौन सा अलाउड है या अलाउड नहीं है वो आप
यहां से कॉन्फ़िगर कर सकते हैं। यहां पे आप
चैन सेटिंग पे करेंगे तो इट विल गेट
हाईलाइटेड। आप इनेबल कर सकते हैं। जैसे
Microsoft एज को अलाऊ करना है। आप डिनाई
कर दोगे ना एज से बाहर रिक्वेस्ट ही नहीं
जा पाएगी आपकी। ब्राउज़र सही से काम नहीं
करेगी आपकी। तो ये आप कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करते
हैं। यहां पे डिटेल्स पे जाएंगे तो
बेसिकली आपको इस पर्टिकुलर अह उसका डिटेल
एंड प्रॉपर्टीज़ आपको मिल जाएगा। यहां पे
आपको स्पेसिफिक कोई ऐप को अलाउ करना है तो
अलाउ अनदर ऐप करेंगे। एंड यहां ब्राउज़
करेंगे तो प्रोग्राम फाइल्स के अंदर जो
इंस्टॉलेशन डायरेक्टरी आपकी होती है ऐप की
वहां से आप ऐप का एग्जीक्यूटेबल सेलेक्ट
करके जो भी फाइल है एग्जीक्यूटेबल का आप
यहां पे उसके स्पेसिफिकली अलऊ कर सकते हैं
या जो भी मतलब डिनाई कर सकते हैं
व्हाटएवर। तो ये होती है। अब इसी में आप
तो Windows Frewl पे आओगे तो यहीं पे आपको
एडवांस सेटिंग्स पे जब आप जाओगे तो यहां
पे रूल्स क्रिएट करने का ऑप्शन आता है।
इनबाउंड एंड आउटबाउंड रूल्स।
दी आर द कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फायरवल कॉन्फ़िगरेशन।
यह एक आती है आपकी इनबाउंड रूल्स जहां पर
आप इनबाउंड रूल्स क्रिएट करते हैं। जब आप
इस पे क्लिक करेंगे, तो यू विल गेट ऑल द
इनबाउंड रूल्स। आउटबाउंड रूल्स बेसिकली जो
बाहर की तरफ ट्रैफिक जा रही है। इनबाउंड
रूल्स जो इनसाइड अंदर की ट्रैफिक आपकी आ
रही है वो इनबाउंड रूल्स हैं। बाहर की तरफ
तो बाहर की ट्रैफिक जो जा रही है वो है।
ये आपकी मॉनिटरिंग है जहां पे आप
मॉनिटरिंग वगैरह सारी डिटेल्स चेक आउट कर
सकते हैं। क्या-क्या रूल्स यहां पे आपके
बने हुए हैं। क्या-क्या रूल्स यहां पे
कॉन्फ़िगर्ड है ये सारी चीजें आप देख सकते
हैं। तो ये सारी चीजें जो है ये आप करते
हैं फायर वाल के अंदर में। तो फायर वाल
क्या करता है? एक बैरियर है बाहर के
नेटवर्क और इनसाइड नेटवर्क में। अब यहां
पे देखिए
है। इट मॉनिटर्स इनकमिंग एंड आउटगोइंग
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक एंड फिल्टर्स एनी
अनअथराइज्ड ट्रैफिक। किसी भी तरह के
अनअथराइज्ड ट्रैफिक को यह फिल्टर करता है।
बाहर के और भीतर के ट्रैफिक अनअथराइज्ड
ट्रैफिक को फ़्टर आउट करता है। बस दैट्स
इट। द फरवर आल्सो हैज़ सम डिटेक्शन रूल्स
डेप्लॉयड। मैंने जैसे बताया इसके भी
डिटेक्शन रूल्स होते हैं। उसी रूल पे काम
करता है। कोई भी सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन एक
रूल सेट ऑफ़ रूल्स पे काम करती है। जो
रूल्स है उसी के अकॉर्डिंग काम करेगी। ठीक
है? व्हिच हेल्प अस आइडेंटिफाई एंड ब्लॉकस
ट्रैफिक बिफोर इट रीचेस द इंटरनल एट। यह
हेल्प करता है कोई भी मलिशियस सस्िशियस
ट्रैफिक है या रिक्वेस्ट है या अह पैकेट
है उसको अंदर इंटरनल मेन नेटवर्क तक ना
पहुंचा जाए। उससे हेल्प करता है फायर वाल
आपका सिंपल। अब देखो इसके अलावा देयर आर
सेवरल अदर सिक्योरिटी सॉलशंस व्हिच प्ले
इंपॉर्टेंट यूनिक रोल इन एसोसिएशन
एनवायरमेंट। जैसे कि एंटीवायरस। एंटीवायरस
का बहुत बड़ा रोल है।
यस। इनबाउंड मींस इनकमिंग, आउटबाउंड मींस
आउटगोइंग।
एंटीवायरस का बहुत बड़ा रोल है। ईपीपी एक
होते हैं। एंड पॉइंट प्रोटेक्शन
प्लेटफार्म। ईपीपीस भी होते हैं। एंड
पॉइंट प्रोटेक्शन प्लेटफार्म एक पूरा का
पूरा प्लेटफार्म आईडीएस आईपीएस ये आपको
पता होगा इंट्रोसन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम।
इंट्रोसन प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम जो इंट्रोसंस
को डिटेक्ट या प्रिवेंट करती है। एक्सडीआर
एक्सटेंडेड डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस। यह तो
आपका ईडीआर है। इसी का एक एक्सटेंडेड
वर्जन जो हो गया वो एक्सडीआर कहलाता है।
तो एक्सटेंडेड डिटेक्शन एंड रिस्पांस
एक्सडीआर या सोर सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रन
ऑटोमेशन एंड रिस्पांस बेसिकली सोर
प्लेटफार्म जो सोर सॉलशंस होते हैं। ये एक
सिक्योरिटी ऑर्केस्ट्रॉन सिक्योरिटी को
ऑर्केस्ट्रेट करना कैसे मतलब उसको सिमिलर
तरीके से सिक्योरिटी को इंप्लीमेंट करना
उसको ऑटोमेट करना एंड किसी भी तरह के
थ्रेट को या किसी भी तरह के जैसे अटैक या
वेक्टर्स को रिसोंड करना तो इस तरह के भी
टूल्स या सॉलशंस होते हैं। अब ये डिसीजन
कि कौन सी टेक्नोलॉजी डिप्लॉय होगी वो
डिपेंड करता है किस तरह का थ्रेट सरफेस है
एक कंपनी का एंड क्या रिसोर्सेज अवेलेबल
है एक कंपनी के अंदर में। अब कंपनी
छोटी-मोटी है तो यार इतनी चीजें नहीं
करेंगी वो कभी भी बट अगर बड़ी कंपनी है
जैसे मान लो Microsoft Google है
लाइक Infosys है, विp्रो है, HCL है, HP
है ये बड़ी कंपनीज़ है। एज अ Samsung है। सो
दे डिप्लॉय दिस काइंड ऑफ़ XDR,
आईडीएस,
सो ईपीपी ये सारी चीज़ वो डिप्लॉय करते
हैं। दैट्स इट। एक्सडीआर और ईडीआर में
डिफरेंस है। बताऊंगा वो भी बताऊंगा। देखो
हर चीज़ आपके पास आएंगी। मैं आपको यही चीज
बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं और आपको थोड़ी
खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर करनी है। जब मैं कोई
टॉपिक बताता हूं तो जब आप ट्रेनिंग खत्म
कर लेते हैं जब आपकी ये क्लास खत्म हो जाए
और जब आपके पास एक या दो दिन का बीच का
गैप होगा ना उस बै उस उस पर्टिकुलर गैप के
अंदर में आपको जो टॉपिक्स मैंने बताए हैं
उसको थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर खुद से भी करना है।
तभी मजा आएगा और नोट्स बनाने हैं। की
पॉइंट्स को Lindin पे पोस्ट करके और हमें
टैग करना है। ये मैंडेटरी आपका है। एंड
गारंटी मैं आपको बिलीव बिलीव मी आप ये जब
चीजें प्रोसेससेस जब करोगे एंड जब ये
ट्रेनिंग खत्म हो जाएगी तो आप जब उस नोट्स
को की पॉइंट्स को देखोगे तो आपको जो
बेनिफिट मिलेगा ना वैसा बेनिफिट आपको कभी
नहीं मिलेगा। कहीं नहीं मिला होगा। आपको
मजा आएगा। आप सोचोगे कि अरे यार सर आपने
बिल्कुल सही बोला था। एकदम तगड़ी
एडवाइस दी थी एंड आपको मजा आएगा।
दैट्स इट। सब हां सब सब बताऊंगा। ये टूल्स
हैं। टूल्स हैं। टूल्स को इंस्टॉलेशन करनी
पड़ती है। कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करनी पड़ती है। तो ये
टूल्स है। इस पे भी हम काम करेंगे। हम
एसआईएम अलग-अलग एसआईएम टूल्स पे काम
करेंगे। सो बिल्कुल ओपन सोर्स एसआईएम टू
ओपन सोर्स टूल्स भी आते हैं। उस पे भी काम
करेंगे। मेरे पास तो वाजू के प्रमोशन का
भी ऑफर आया था एक बार। बट क्योंकि वो
अच्छा मतलब
काइंड ऑफ कि
कंडीशंस उनके कुछ अलग थे। कुछ खास अच्छा
कंडीशन मुझे लगा नहीं था तो मैंने उसको
रिजेक्ट कर दिया था। वजू आपको पता होगा
वजू इज़ अ ओपन सोर्स अ एसआईएम काइंड ऑफ
टूल्स मतलब एसआईएम टूल्स की तरह होते हैं।
राइट? तो टेंशन आपको नहीं लेना है। सारी
चीजें जो हैं आपको मैं सिखाऊंगा। आपको मैं
बताऊंगा। बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए।
अब आते हैं सिक्योरिटी डिपार्टमेंट्स के
ऊपर में।
सिक्योरिटी डिपार्टमेंट्स के ऊपर में इन
टाइनी कंपनी आईटी डिपार्टमेंट्स टेक्स रोल
ऑफ सिक्योरिंग द कंपनी छोटी कंपनी है जैसे
मान लो हमारी छोटी कंपनी है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
मान लो डिफ्रonिक्स छोटी कंपनी है तो
हमारी कंपनी में आईटी डिपार्टमेंट ही
हैंडल कर लेगी सिक्योरिटी को ठीक है जो
सिक्योरिटी में छोटा सा टीम होगा कर लेगा
स्मॉल टू मीडियम साइज कंपनीज़ मे हैव अ
जेनरिक इनेशन सिक्योरिटी टीम दैट डज़ ऑल
शॉर्ट ऑफ़ टास्क जैसे मान लो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
स्मॉल टू मीडियम साइज़ कंपनी तो उसमें एक
जेरिक सिक्योरिटी टीम होगी जो सारे काम
हैंडल कर लेगी। बट बिगर कंपनीज़ हैव अ
सीआईएसओ
ओवरसीइंग ऑल द सिक्योरिटी टीम्स। बट बड़ी
कंपनीज़ के अंदर सीआईएसओस होते हैं। चीफ
इनेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर
चीफ इनफेशन सिक्योरिटी ऑफिसर जो किसको
देखते हैं? एसओसी मैनेजर जिसके अंदर में
एसओसी मैनेजर आते हैं और उसके अंदर में
फिर L1, L2, L3 ये सब आ जाते हैं। कंपनी
छोटी है, काम बड़े हैं। थैंक यू। थैंक यू।
बग बंटी के लिए सर शुड आई बाय मैक Mac M4
Pro? हां, Mac M4 Pro का 16GB एंड 512 GB
SSD ले लो। बढ़िया है।
ठीक है। अब बड़ी कंपनीज़ में क्या होती है?
रेड टीम होती है, जीआरसी टीम होती है,
ब्लू टीम होती है। ठीक है? ये तीन चीजें
मेनली होती है। रेड टीमिंग रेड टीमस जो
रेड टीम होती है, वो क्या करती है?
ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट्स होते हैं।
पेंटेस्टर्स होते हैं, एथिकल हैकर्स होते
हैं हु लुक फॉर सिक्योरिटी इशज़। ये रेड
टीमिंग का काम होता है। जीआरसी क्या होते
हैं? गवर्नेंस रिस्क एंड कंप्लायंसेस इसको
कहा जाता है। ये स्पेशलिस्ट होते हैं जो
मैनेज करते हैं पॉलिसीज को एंड इंश्योर
कंपाइल कंप्लायंस विद रेगुलेटरीज लाइक
पीसीआई डीएसएस जो पेमेंट्स कार्ड
इंडस्ट्री अ डाटा सिक्योरिटी स्टैंडर्ड जो
होती है इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है। देख लेना
मैं अगर गलत बोल रहा होगा तो इसका फुल
फॉर्म तुम भाई देख लेना। फुल फॉर्म पे मत
जाना यार। ये मत बोलना कि सर फुल फॉर्म
गलत बोल दिया। ये कभी-कभी होता है। बट देख
लेना। आई थिंक पेमेंट कार्ड इंडस्ट्री
डाटा सिक्योरिटी स्टैंडर्ड यही होता है
मुझे एग्जैक्टली। तो इसके इससे कंप्लायंस
के लिए इससे कंप्लायंट के लिए एंड पॉलिसीज
को मैनेज करने के लिए जीआरसी टीम होती है।
ब्लू टीम होते हैं डिफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट्स लाइक एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट
इंजीनियर्स एंड इंसिडेंट रिसोंडर्स। तो आप
ब्लू टीमर्स हैं। आप कौन है? ब्लू टीम है।
ब्लू टीम अपने आप को प्राउडली बोलो। ब्लू
टीम। ये ब्लू टीम कोर्स है भाई। ये
कंप्लीट ब्लू टीम कोर्स है। तो यू आर अ
ब्लू टीमर। रेड टीमिंग तो आप ऑलरेडी कर
रहे हो। याद है ना? रेड टीमी पेंटेस्टर्स
जो बग बंटी के कोर्स हैं आपके हमारे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पे जिसमें कि पता नहीं कितने
वीडियोस है 56 वीडियोस हैं वो आपका रेड
टीमिंग का ही पार्ट है ऑलरेडी फ्री में
डाला है ब्लू टीमिंग ऑलरेडी यहां पे
स्टार्ट कर दी है क्या चाहिए भाई जिंदगी
में कुछ और चाहिए तुम्हें चाहिए तो बताओ
ठीक है
अब यहां पे जो वही चीज मैंने बताया था कि
L1 L2 इंजीनियर एंड मैनेजर ये मैंने
ऑलरेडी बता दी थी। अब देखो यहां पे एक और
चीज आती है। एक और चीज आती है। इफ एसओसी
एक्सपीरिय एक्सपर्टीज इज नॉट इनफ और द
इंसिडेंट इंसिडेंट गोज़ आउट ऑफ कंट्रोल।
अगर मान लो कोई ऐसा इंसिडेंट होता है जो
जिसमें एसओसी वाले की मतलब
नहीं चल पा रही। एसओसी के बस की बाहर की
बात हो। ऐसा होगा कई बार होता है। एसओसी
के बस की बाहर की बात हो जाती है। तो हम
उस टाइम अर्जेंटली बोलते हैं फायर फाइटर्स
को बुलाते हैं। म
ये वाली चीज हम उनको जल्दी से बुलाते हैं।
वो कौन होते हैं? वो होते हैं सीआईआरटी।
वो होते हैं सीआईआरटी।
साइबर इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम या फिर आप
इसको एक और नाम से जानते हैं सर्ट सी
ईआरटी कंप्यूटर इमरजेंसी रिस्पांस टीम
सर्ट इन इंडिया का ये है सर्ट इन अलग-अलग
कंट्रीज में अलग-अलग नाम होते हैं। तो
मोस्ट कॉमनली एंड एक एवरेज जो एक नाम है
वह है सीआईआरटी साइबर इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस
टीम आल्सो कॉल्ड सीएसआईआरटी
सीएसआईआरटी जो कि कंप्यूटर सिक्योर
सिक्योरिटी इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम हो गया
एंड सर्ट कंप्यूटर इमरजेंसी रिस्पांस टीम
यह भी इसको बोला जाता है सीएसआईआरटी और
सीआईआरटी और सीईआरटी एवरीथिंग कुछ भी बोल
सकते हैं। द मेंबर्स शुड हैव अ ब्रॉड
नॉलेज ऑफ़ साइबर थ्रेट्स एंड हैंडल ब्रचेस
विदाउट डिपेंडिंग ऑन टूल्स लाइक ईडीआर और
एसआईएम। अब ये जो बंदे होते हैं खतरनाक
बंदे होते हैं ये डिपेंड नहीं करते ईडीआर
और एसआईएम टूल्स पे। इनके पास इनफ बहुत
अच्छी बहुत खतरनाक नॉलेज होती है। जब कोई
बहुत हाई लेवल की क्रिटिकल
ऐसी कोई अटैक होती है। उस समय हमारे
सीआईआरटी साइबर इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस टीम या
सर्ट जो कि इंडिया का क्या है भैया?
इंडिया का क्या है? मैं आपको इंडिया का
बताता हूं। अगर आपको नहीं पता तो दिस इज
सर्टेन। अगर आप इंडिया का देखेंगे तो
इंडिया का यह है आपका सर्टेन। इसको सर्ट
इन इसलिए आई एन इसलिए जोड़ा जाता है
इंडिया को रिप्रेजेंट करने के लिए। सो
यहां पे क्या है? सर्ट इन। सो व्हाई दिस
इज़ दिस इज़ सर्ट का मतलब क्या है यहां पे?
अ कंप्यूटर इमरजेंसी रिस्पांस टीम। ये
इसका फुल फॉर्म है। एंड आई इंडियन इंडियन
को रिप्रेजेंट करती है। तो ये है हमारे
सर्टेन। तो दिस इज वेरी वेरी खतरनाक टीम।
खतरनाक टीम है ये सर्टिन वाले। ठीक है?
तो अगर ऐसा कोई ब्रच होता है जो एसओसी के
बस की बात नहीं है। एसओसी से आउट ऑफ
कंट्रोल हो जाता है तो वहां पे हमारे
सीआईआरटी या शर्ट वाले बंदे आते हैं जो
फायर फाइटर्स कहलाते हैं। अब यह मुझे बताओ
कि एज अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट क्या तुम ये क्या
तुम इस तरह की कोई सिचुएशन आने दोगे? चाहे
वो किसी भी लेवल के आप हो। क्या आप ऐसी
सिचुएशन आने दोगे जहां पर शर्ट या यह फायर
फाइटर्स को बुलाना पड़े? या आप ही हैंडल
कर लोगे सारी चीजें? बताइए। हैंडल करोगे
कि बुलाना पड़ेगा फायर फाइटर्स को? हैंडल
पहले ही हार मान लोगे या यू विल बी लाइक
कि नहीं यार हम ही करेंगे?
मोस्टली नहीं। हैंडल कर लोगे?
गुड गुड गुड।
बढ़िया अच्छी बात है। अब यहां पे आते हैं
ह्यूमन अटैक वेक्टर्स इन एसओसी। अब ये अब
हम आते हैं ह्यूमन अटैक वेक्टर्स पे।
क्योंकि ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है ह्यूमन
अटैक वेक्टर्स। क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है? मैं
आपको बताता हूं। धीरे-धीरे हम आगे बढ़ रहे
हैं। धीरे-धीरे हम फिशिंग वाले पार्ट पे आ
रहे हैं। क्योंकि सबसे पहला इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज वही है। ह्यूमन अटैक वेक्टर्स क्या
है? अब देखो यहां पे इस पे आने से पहले
मैं एक चीज और बताना चाहता हूं कि हर
कंपनी हर ऑर्गेनाइजेशन जरूरी नहीं है कि
उसका खुद का एक एसओसी टीम हो क्योंकि
एसओसी टीम रखना ऑपरेट करना यह बहुत
कॉस्टली हो सकता है। बहुत ज्यादा
कॉम्प्लेक्स हो सकता है। तो बहुत सारी ऐसी
कंपनीज़ है ना जो छोटी मीडियम साइज कंपनी
है वो एमएसएसपी पे एम डबल एमएसएसपी पे
डिपेंड करती है। ये होते हैं मैनेज्ड
सिक्योरिटी सर्विस प्रोवाइडर। मतलब ये जो
है ना एसओसी की सर्विज आपको प्रोवाइड करते
हैं कंपनीज़ को। जैसे मान लो एडब्ल्यूएस है
वो अलग-अलग तरह की सर्विज प्रोवाइड करता
है। तो आपको अपना खुद का डेडिकेटेड वीपीएस
या डेडिकेटेड कोई ऐसा रखने की जरूरत नहीं
है। कोई टू मतलब सर्वर या कुछ ऐसा
एडब्ल्यूएस से आप सर्विस ले रहे हो।
एडब्ल्यूएस इज़ गिविंग यू अ सर्विस।
एडब्ल्यूएस आपको लोड बैलेंसर की भी
फैसिलिटी दे रहा है। स्टोरेज की भी
फैसिलिटी दे रहा है। इलास्टिसिटी इलास्टिक
आईपी भी प्रोवाइड कर रहा है। आपको बैंडविथ
भी दे रहा है। सब कुछ दे रहा है। उसी
तरीके से इन एसओसीस देयर इज़ एमएसएसपी
जो कि होते हैं मैनेज्ड सिक्योरिटी सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर। अगर कोई ऐसी कंपनी है जो एसओसी
की टीम को मैनेज नहीं कर पा रही, हैंडल
नहीं कर पा रही है, बहुत ज्यादा खर्च हो
रहा है तो एमएसएसपी की सर्विज लेते हैं।
दैट डिलीवरर्स आउटसोर्स सिक्योरिटी सर्विज
मोस्टली कॉमनली एसओसी टू इट्स क्लाइंट्स।
बस दैट्स इट।
अब यहां पर हम आते हैं। हां डॉगेश भाई जो
हैं वो पीछे अपना
डॉग फाइटिंग कर रहे हैं। डॉग डॉगेस भाई
अपनी
बताओ बहुत ज्यादा बहुत जोर से बोल रहा था
डॉगेस भाई। अब आते हैं व्हाई ह्यूमंस आर
टारगेटेड। अब हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ रहे हैं
थोड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी के साथ धीरे-धीरे।
अब जब आगे बढ़ेंगे और भी कॉम्प्लेक्स
आएगा। ह्यूमन अटैक वेक्टर्स इन एसओसी। ये
क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है? क्योंकि जब एसओसी के
एनवायरमेंट के अंदर जो ट्राई होते हैं, जो
अलर्ट्स हो रहे हैं, जो चीजें आ रही है
ना, उसमें सबसे ज्यादा अटैक ह्यूमंस के
ऊपर होता है। ऐसा क्यों होता है? मैं आपको
एक एग्जांपल के थ्रू पूछता हूं। अब मुझे
आप दो ऑप्शन देता हूं। आपको आंसर करना है
दोनों में से। कौन सा आप चूज़ करेंगे? पहला
ऑप्शन एक। पहला ऑप्शन वन ऑप्शन यह है
फर्स्ट ऑप्शन कि एक कंपनी के ऊपर मान लो
एक इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर मान लो आपको
अटैक करना है। आप एक हैकर हैं जिसको यह
लोग डिटेक्ट कर रहे हैं। तो जब आप अटैक
करने वाले हो तो पहला ऑप्शन आपके पास यह
है फर्स्ट ऑप्शन कि आप उस कंपनी के
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर या वेबसाइट या जो
भी है वेबसाइट ही है मान लो उसका सर्वर है
उसमें वेलेबिलिटीज फाइंड करो उसको
एक्सप्लइट करो उसको प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट
करो और फिर सेंसिटिव इनेशन निकालो दूसरा
ऑप्शन है कि आप उसी एक कंपनी के किसी उस
लेवल ऑफ एक्सेस के एंप्लई को एक्सप्लइट
करो और उसे सारी डिटेल लो किसी भी तरीके
से मैनपुलेट करके एक्सप्लइट करके डिटेल्स
ले लो। तो ऑप्शन ए में था एक वनेबिलिटी
एक्सप्लइट करना। ऑप्शन टू में था एक
एंप्लई को एक्सप्लइट करना। आपके लिए आपके
अकॉर्डिंग सबसे इजी वे एंड सबसे मतलब लेस
टाइम टेकिंग वे कौन सा हो सकता है?
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इट विल बी ऑलवेज ऑप्शन
टू। जो ऑप्शन वन बोल रहे हैं वो तब समझ
नहीं पा रहे हैं मेरी बात। ना तो ध्यान दे
रहे हैं मुझे लगता है। इट्स आंसर इज़ सिंपल
ऑप्शन टू। यह ऑप्शन टू ही रहेगा।
तो इसीलिए ह्यूमंस पे सबसे ज्यादा अटैक
होती है और ह्यूमन अटैक को सरकमवेंट करना
या ह्यूमन अटैक को मिटिगेट करना काउंटर
मेजर करना बहुत मुश्किल काम है। एंड इस
पर्टिकुलर तरीके को इस पर्टिकुलर प्रोसेस
को जिसमें ह्यूमंस को मैनपुलेट करते हैं
टू गिव सेंसिटिव इनफेशन इसको क्या बोलते
हैं बताइए? आप में से कोई अगर एथिकल
हैकिंग का स्टूडेंट है या नॉलेज होगा
साइबर एथिकल हैकिंग का बेसिक नॉलेज तो
उसको ये टर्म पता होगा। इसको क्या बोलते
हैं?
करेक्ट। इसको हम सोशल इंजीनियरिंग बोलते
हैं। इस टैक्टिक को सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
बोलते हैं। बिल्कुल सही। अटैक ह्यूमंस आर
टारगेटेड बिकॉज़ द एक्सेस दे कैन प्रोवाइड
टू वेबसाइट मेल बॉक्सेस और डेटाबेस। सम
थ्रेट एक्टर्स हंट फॉर अ स्पेसिफिक एक्सेस
व्हाइल अदर्स नॉट सो सेलेक्टिव। कुछ एक्ट
जो थ्रेट एक्टर्स होते हैं वो स्पेसिफिक
एक्सेस के लिए ह्यूमंस को अटैक करते हैं।
कुछ किसी को भी अटैक कर देंगे और बाद में
देखेंगे कि हां किसका इंफॉर्मेशनेशन किस
चीज के लिए यूज़ करना है। अटैक्स टारगेटिंग
ह्यूमंस शेयर अ कॉमन ट्रेट। दे रिलाई ऑन
मैनपुलेटिंग द विक्टिम इंटू हेल्पिंग द
अटैकर्स वेदर नोइंग नोइंगली ऑ नॉट। यह
मैनपुलेट करते हैं ह्यूमंस को विक्टिम को
ताकि वो हेल्प करें अटैकर्स की। एंड इसी
टैक्टिक को सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कहा जाता है।
इस टैक्टिक को सोशल इंजीनियरिंग कहा जाता
है। एंड इट वर्क्स बाय एक्सप्लइटिंग
ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी रेदर देन टेक्निकल फ्लॉ।
इसमें ह्यूमन साइकोलॉजी को अटैक किया जाता
है। एक्सप्लइट किया जाता है। अभी आपने
रिसेंटली सुना होगा बहुत सारे केसेस आए
हैं डिजिटल अरेस्ट के। आपने आपको पता है
डिजिटल अरेस्ट।
डू यू नो डिजिटल अरेस्ट बहुत पॉपुलर हुई
है एक टर्म रिसेंटली बहुत आई है। आपके
मोबाइल पर भी किसी को कॉल करते थे तो इससे
रिलेटेड हमारे बिग बी के आवाज में आपको
अलर्ट किया जाता था, अवेयर किया जाता था।
तो डिजिटल अरेस्ट में भी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
का बहुत बड़ा रोल है। बिना सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के डिजिटल अरेस्ट कैन नॉट एवर
बी सक्सेसफुल।
ये बात। तो ह्यूमन को मैनपुलेट करना है,
ह्यूमन के माइंड को मैनपुलेट करना है। और
ये सबसे बड़ा साइबर अटैक है। एंड केविन
मिटनिक वाज़ वन ऑफ द ग्रेटेस्ट सोशल
इंजीनियर।
जिन्होंने अपने अर्ली लाइफ से ही सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का यूज़ करके पता नहीं कितने
बड़े-बड़े
लोकेशनेशंस पे अटैक करा।
दैट्स द थिंग। सो
रेस्पेक्ट टू दैट पर्सन।
फॉर योर काइंड इन ही इज़ नो मोर बट ही वास
द ग्रेटेस्ट हैकर ऑफ ऑल टाइम ग्रेटेस्ट
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग सोशल इंजीनियर ऑफ ऑल
टाइम फॉर द टैक्टिक्स टू सक्सीड इट इज़ डिज़
टू बी दो चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट है इसमें
ट्रस्टवर्दी एंड इमोशनल द अटैकर मस्ट
अपीयर लेजिटमेट टू द विक्टिम ट्रस्ट्स देम
सो द विक्टिम ट्रस्ट देम अब ट्रस्टवर्दी
होना जरूरी है जो विक्टिम जिसप आप अटैक कर
रहे हो ना उसके ट्रस्ट को जीतना
उससे उससे आपको ट्रस्ट गेन करना है। तभी
तो विक्टिम जो है ना वह ट्रस्ट करेगा। एंड
विक्टिम आपको डिटेल्स देगा। एंड दूसरा है
इमोशनल। द अटैक मस्ट ट्रिगर फीलिंग्स लाइक
अर्जेंसी, फियर और क्यूरियसिटी।
इमोशंस को एक्सप्लइट करना। जैसे किसी चीज
की अर्जेंसी, किसी चीज का डर,
क्यूरियसिटी। इमरजेंसी मतलब एक एंप्लई को
एक नॉर्मल एक नॉर्मल लेवल ऑफ एक्सेस किसी
एंप्लई का है। उसके पास कंपनी के एसओसी
मैनेजर का मेल आ जाता है। मान लो एसओसी
एल1 का कोई एंप्लई है। उसको एसओसी मैनेजर
का मेल आता है रात को 1:00 बजे कि आई एम
लॉक्ड आउट ऑफ दिस पर्टिकुलर सिस्टम। आई
नीड टू एक्सेस इट राइट अवे। गिव योर
क्रेडेंशियल सो दैट आई कैन एक्सेस थ्रू
यू। अब इसको लगेगा अरे मैनेजर का कॉल
मैनेजर का मेल आ गया। मैनेजर का कॉल आ
गया। ये तो बड़ा और रात को 1:00 बजे आया
यार कुछ ना कुछ अर्जेंट होगी। मैं नहीं
दूंगा तो फिर बाद में मेरी बैंड बजेगी। तो
इस तरह से अगर आपने फिर भी नहीं दिया। ये
क्या हुआ? अर्जेंसी क्रिएट करना होगा। ठीक
है? अर्जेंसी। अब आपने नहीं दिया वहां पे
क्रेडेंशियल डिटेल्स तो अब वापस से मेल
आएगा कि गिव
रियल फास्ट। अदरवाइज अह बेसिकली
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल इंक्वायरी वुड बी वुड बी
देयर फॉर अगेंस्ट यू। बिकॉज़ यू आर नॉट
कंप्लाइंग विद द सिक्योरिटी। प्रोवाइड द
डिटेल्स बिकॉज़ आवर सिक्योरिटी इज एट शेक।
तो यह डर पैदा हो जाएगा कि अरे भाई ये तो
सिक्योरिटी खतरे में है। दोबारा मेला गया
दे दो।
ये चीजें क्रिएट करनी होती है। ये चीजें
इंपॉर्टेंट होती है। एंड ह्यूमंस को
टारगेट कैसे किए जा सकते हैं? ह्यूमंस को
फिशिंग अटैक्स के थ्रू टारगेट किए जाते
हैं। मैलवेयर डाउनलोड्स करके किए जाते
हैं। डीप फेक्स के थ्रू किए जाते हैं।
इंपर्शनेशन के थ्रू किए जाते हैं। अदर
अटैक जैसे कि लॉगिन या फिजिकल अटैक्स इनके
थ्रू किए जाते हैं। और फिशिंग अटैक्स आपको
पता ही है। एक क्लोन एक लेजिटमेट वेबसाइट
का लेजिटमेट पोर्टल लेजिटमेट प्लेटफार्म
का क्लोन बना देना। सेम टू सेम दिखता हुआ
क्लोन बना देना। और उसके थ्रू अटेम्प्ट
करना। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का यूज़
करके उस बंदे तक बंदे को अटेमप्ट करना
लिंक [हंसी] कोई एसएमएस लिंक के थ्रू
ईमेल्स के थ्रू या डायरेक्टली फोन
टेलीफोनिक कॉल के थ्रू जिसको
विशिंग बोलते हैं स्मिशिंग बोलते हैं
एसएमएस के थ्रू ये चीजें ये फिशिंग अटैक
के अंदर कहलाती है और आपको जान के बहुत
हैरानी होगी कि दुनिया में एक दो तीन 100
नहीं हजारों लाखों ऐसी फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स
हैं जो ऑपरेट करती हैं। एंड इसके लिए मैं
आपको एक वेबसाइट बताता हूं जिसका नाम है
फिश टैंक।
आप फिश टैंक पे जाएंगे हियर यू विल सर्च
फॉर फिश टैंक। एंड यहां पे आपको दिखेगा कि
यह एक एक कम्युनिटी ड्रिवन प्लेटफार्म है।
बेसिकली यहां पे जिसको कि बेसिकली
कम्युनिटी ड्रिवन मैं ज्यादा नहीं
बोलूंगा। बट ये एक
यू कैन से सिस्को कम्युनिटी।
sिस्को टैलोस इंटेलिजेंस ग्रुप के द्वारा
मैनेज किया जाता है। एंड यहां पर लिस्ट
हैं उन वेबसाइट्स के जो पोटेंशियली
फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स के कैटेगरी में आते हैं।
पोटेंशियल फिशिंग वेबसाइट के कैटेगरी में
आते हैं। आप देख सकते हो और यहां पे आप
किसी वेबसाइट को चेक भी कर सकते हो कि इज़
दैट वेबसाइट ऑफ़ फिशिंग वेबसाइट। और आप
यहां पे लिस्ट देख सकते हो। आप यहां पे
देखोगे तो यह पूरी की पूरी आपको लिस्ट जो
है यहां पे मैंने यहां पे किया। ये पूरी
आपको लिस्ट दिखेगी। यहां पे आपको ओल्डर पे
जाओगे तो ओल्डर दिखेगी। यहां पे आप देख
सकते हो ये सारे ऑनलाइन है। ये फिशिंग
वेबसाइट्स हैं गाइस। दीज़ आर फिशिंग
वेबसाइट्स। ये फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स हैं।
यू विल नॉट बिलीव। देखो ये देखो यहां पे
जो ऑपरेट कर रही है। ऑनलाइन है। ये देखो
ऑनलाइन है। कुछ-कुछ ऑफलाइन में बहुत सारे
आपको पुराने पे जाओगे तो यहां पे ऑफलाइन
भी दिखेगी। बट ऑनलाइन भी। अब यहां पे आपको
कोई फिशिंग वेबसाइट रिपोर्ट करनी है तो ऐड
अ फिश पे क्लिक करोगे। यहां पे अकाउंट
अपना रजिस्टर कर लेना लॉगिन करके और
फ़िशिंग वेबसाइट को यहां पे रजिस्टर कर
सकते हो। यहां पे बता सकते हो। इनको
इनफ़ॉर्म कर सकते हो। फ़िश सर्च पे यहां पे
कर लोगे कि वैलिड क्या है? वैलिड फिशेस
इनवैलिड या अननोन? ऑनलाइन है या ऑफलाइन
है। कौन से करने हैं? तो वैलिड फिशेस
करोगे एंड यहां पे ऑनलाइन करोगे, सर्च
करोगे तो यू विल गेट द लिस्ट जहां पे
वैलिड और जो ऑनलाइन अभी भी काम कर रहे
हैं। ये वेबसाइट्स है। कुछ-कुछ वेबसाइट्स
को आप एक्सेस कर भी सकते हो। हो सकता है
कुछ-कुछ आपकी वेबसाइट एक्सेस ना भी हो।
जैसे मान लो ये कोई वेबसाइट है। अब मैं
यहां पे ये चला रहा हूं। सो दिस काइंड ऑफ़
वेबसाइट देखो ये ये देखो इस पे रीडायरेक्ट
हो रही है। ये दिस इज़ अ फिशिंग वेबसाइट।
यू विल यू विल नेवर यू विल नेवर
अंडरस्टैंड दिस कि ये फिशिंग वेबसाइट है।
इसमें अब इंग्लिश लैंग्वेज ही नहीं है
क्या? यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स हैं।
मैं यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स कर देता हूं। अब
सोचो ना
यहां पे सोचो।
यह देखो यह वेबसाइट इस तरीके से चल रही
है। यह जापान की यहां पर जापान वाली
वेबसाइट है। यहां पर यह कोई एप्लीकेशन
काइंड ऑफ
दिस वन इज़ ऑनगोइंग। यहां पे मैं इसको ओपन
करता हूं। दिस इज़ काइंड ऑफ़ फिशिंग
वेबसाइट्स। सो दीज़ आर द फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स
दैट आर बीइंग ऑपरेटेड अलग-अलग। देखो ये
माय ऑथ लॉग इन ऐसे करके कुछ पेज एक खोल
खुल रहा है। एक ओपन हो रहा है। ये देखो ये
Google अगर लॉगउ रहता तो ये आई थिंक
Google की वो चीज़ ओपन होती। मैं यहां पे
न्यू इनकॉग्निटो टैब में करता हूं। अह
वेयर इज़ द इनकॉग्निटो टैब? हां, यहां पे
ओपन करके देखते हैं। व्हाट इज़ एक्सैक्टली
व्हाट इट इज़ ओपनिंग? आई थिंक ये Google का
लॉग इन पेज ओपन करेगा। ये फिशिंग वेबसाइट
है। देखो यूआरएल देखो ऊपर में। हां, ये
Google ओपन कर रहा है। सो, बेसिकली दिस इज़
काइंड ऑफ़ फिशिंग वेबसाइट जो ऑपरेट कर रहा
है। तो, इस तरह से देयर आर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़
फिशिंग वेबसाइट्स दैट आर ऑपरे गेटिंग
ऑपरेटेड। ऑलराइट। एंड अदर जो अटैक्स हैं
जिसमें कि आपका की लॉगिंग है, फिजिकल
अटैक्स ये सब है। अब डिफेंड कैसे करना है?
ह्यूमंस को डिफेंड कैसे करना है? तो
डिफेंड जो है ह्यूमंस का दो तरीके से हो
सकता है। मिटिगेशन एंड डिटेक्शन। मिटिगेशन
एम्स टू प्रिवेंट और रिड्यूस द चांस एंड
इंपैक्ट ऑफ़ अटैक्स। फॉर एग्जांपल बाय
ट्रेनिंग एंप्लई और डिप्लइंग अ गुड एंटी
फिशिंग सॉल्यूशन। यह मिटिगेशन है। तो दो
ही तरीके से आप इसको डिफाइन कर सकते हो।
एक मिटिगेशन और एक डिटेक्शन। तो मिटिगेशन
में अवेयरनेस, ट्रेनिंग या एंटी फिशिंग
सॉलशंस या फिर जो भी अटैक्स हो रहे हैं
उसके अगेंस्ट कोई टूल को आप यूज़ करके कर
सकते हैं। तो ये इस तरीके से डिफेंड होता
है। मिटिगेशन एंड डिटेक्शन। अब यहां पे एज़
अ एसओसी एनालिस्ट, योर टास्क इज़ टू
डिटेक्ट एंड इन्वेस्टिगेट अटैक्स। बिकॉज़
आफ्टर समटाइम्स यू विल बी टायर्ड ऑफ़
मैनुअल मिटिगेशन एंड विल वांट ऑटोमेटेड वे
एंड देयर कम्स द एसओसी सूट ऑफ़ ऑटोमेटेड
सॉलशंस। अब इसी में ऑटोमेटेड सॉलशंस सूट
जो है वो आते हैं आपके जहां पे आप मैनुअली
तो नहीं करोगे इतना तो ऑटोमेटेड सूट्स
चाहिए आपको इन चीजों से डिफेंड करने के
लिए ह्यूमंस को डिफेंड करने के लिए
डिटेक्ट करने के लिए इन्वेस्टिगेट करने के
लिए। तो इसमें आती है आपको एंटी फिशिंग
सॉलशंस आती हैं। एंटीवायरस या ईडीआर या
एक्सडीआर सॉलशंस आते हैं। ट्रस्ट बट
वेरीफाई प्रिंसिपल। ट्रस्ट बट वेरीफाई का
मतलब है कोई आपको कहीं से मेल आता है।
कहीं से कॉल आता है। कोई सीईओ है, सीटीओ
अपने आपको बना के बोल रहा है। तो आप ठीक
है बातों को मानो, समझो। ट्रस्ट कर लो कि
हां भाई ठीक है। बट वेरीफाई जरूर करो। सुन
लो। सारी चीजें सुनो, ट्रस्ट करो। बट डू
वेरीफाई कि एक्चुअली वो सीटीओ है।
एक्चुअली वो सीईओ है। तभी जाके कोई आपको
वहां पे रिस्पांस देना है। एंड सिक्योरिटी
अवेयरनेस ट्रेनिंग जो कि सबका गुरु है
यहां पे। बिना इसके तो कुछ नहीं हो सकता
है कि सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस की ट्रेनिंग
एंप्लाइजज़ को टाइम टू टाइम मिलती रहनी
चाहिए। जैसे-जैसे अपडेट्स होते रहते हैं।
अलग-अलग थ्रेट एक्टर्स, अलग-अलग थ्रेट
वेक्टर्स इमर्ज होते रहते हैं टाइम टाइम
के साथ। उन थ्रेट वेक्टर्स के अगेंस्ट
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस की ट्रेनिंग देनी
जरूरी है। हां बिल्कुल सुनो सबकी करो
अपनी। बिल्कुल सही बात है। सुनो सबकी करो
अपनी। ये सॉरी
तो ये पूरा का पूरा एक फंडा था जिसको हमने
अभी देखा यहां पे जिसको हमने यहां पे समझा
है। डिफेंडिंग ऑफ ह्यूमंस। इन चीजों को
हमने देखा। इससे आप डिफेंड करते हैं। दिस
इज द मेन थिंग। ये थी आपकी इस पर्टिकुलर अ
सेकंड डे के ये पार्ट्स जिसको कि हम यहां
पे अ कंक्लूड करते हैं कंप्लीट करते हैं।
अब इसके बाद अब एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज सुन लो।
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्यों है? मैं आपको बताता
हूं। अब इसके बाद जो क्लासेस आएंगी आपकी
उसमें लेवल धीरे-धीरे आपका बढ़ेगा।
धीरे-धीरे कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी बढ़ेगी। ये बात
याद रखिएगा। 1ढ़ घंटे की ऑलमोस्ट मैं रख
रहा हूं। आपके आपने ही बोला था सर एक से
डेढ़ घंटे तो एक घंटा तो काफी कम हो जाता
है। पर डेढ़ घंटा हम चलाएंगे। बट
धीरे-धीरे लेवल सब इनक्रीस होंगे। और यही
बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स हर लेवल इनक्रीस में भी
बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स होगा। जैसे मैं लेवल
इनक्रीस करूंगा उसमें भी बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स
होंगे। वो बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स ही आपको वो
एक्सटेंडेड लेवल और आपके जो
कॉम्प्लेक्स लेवल्स हैं उसको समझने में
हेल्प करेंगे।
तो यह बताइए आप में से कितने लोगों को
एक्चुअली मजा आ रहा है? मुझे जानना है।
जस्ट लेट मी नो इन द चैट।
मजा आ रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा है? बताओ मुझे
मजा आ रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा है? लेट मी
नो।
आ रहा है ना भाई?
आ रहा है। चैट से तो लग रहा है कि आ रहा
है। अच्छी बात है। ग्रेट।
[हंसी]
चलिए अब यहां पर आ जाते हैं एक बार।
ओके मजा आ रहा है। चैट बॉक्स में आ रहा
है। ठीक है।
सर मजा आ रहा है। अभी 30 मिनट तक और ले
लो। नहीं ठीक है। 1.5 आवर्स तक रखते हैं।
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अभी अभी तो
प्रैक्टिकल स्लैब्स और ये सब चीजें आएंगी।
बहुत ही ज्यादा मजा आ रहा है। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। तो वीडियो को शेयर जरूर कर
दीजिएगा आप लोग। अगर मजा आ रहा है तो
वीडियो को प्लीज शेयर कीजिएगा। अच्छा आप
में से शेयर करते हैं वीडियोस को। ये जो
वीडियो है एसओसीस के जैसे डे वन की हो गई।
आज डे टू की आपकी वीडियो हो गई। तो आप लोग
अपने कम्युनिटी में या अपने जो भी आपके
WhatsApp, Facebook ग्रुप्स या Telegram
ग्रुप्स होते हैं या Instagram वगैरह तो
आप शेयर करते हैं। मतलब मैं फोर्स नहीं कर
रहा शेयर करने के लिए। बट अगर आप करते हैं
तो इट्स आवर प्रिविलेज एंड वी आर ट्रूली
ग्रेटफुल फॉर दैट। बिकॉज़ यह शेयर करने का
मेरा मोटिव यह है मेनली कि यह सब जगह
पहुंचे। उन लोगों तक पहुंचे जिनको अभी तक
नहीं पता है। बस मैं यही चाहता हूं।
पहुंचाना आपका काम है। ट्रेनिंग जिस
कंटेंट जिस लेवल की मैंने आपको प्रॉमिस
करी है वो लेवल का कंटेंट देना और आपको
जॉब रेडी सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट एल वन यानी
कि एसोसी एनालिस्ट एल1 बनाना वो मेरी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है। वो आप मेरे ऊपर छोड़
दीजिए।
बाकी शेयर करना, हर जगह इसको फैला देना,
लोगों तक पहुंचा देना। जो बिगिनर्स हैं,
न्यू कमर्स हैं, जो ऑलरेडी एक्सपीरियंस्ड
है या जो इसमें इंटरेस्टेड है, जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में इंटरेस्टेड है उन तक
पहुंचा देना। यह आपके हाथ में है। लाइक
ठोकना आपके हाथ में है। लाइव में ज्यादातर
लाइव अटेंड करना ताकि मैं भी मोटिवेटेड
रहूं। यह आपके हाथ में है। याद रखिएगा जिस
दिन आप डीमोटिवेट डीमोटिवेटेड हो जाएंगे
फ्रीक्वेंसी क्लास की ऑटोमेटिक कम हो
जाएगी और मैं भी डीमोटिवेट हो जाऊंगा। मैं
आपको क्लियर बता दे रहा हूं। मैं कोई ऐसे
शुगर कोटिंग और ये सब नहीं बातें करता
क्योंकि मैं आपके लिए यहां पे हूं। आपके
लिए अगर मैं इस लेवल की ट्रेनिंग दे रहा
हूं तो मैं आपसे थोड़ी एक्सपेक्टेशंस कम
से कम ये सब चीजें कर सकता हूं। मैं आपसे
कोई पैसा वैसा नहीं मांग रहा। सिंपल सा
फंडा है। तो प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। ठीक
है?
ओके। सभी लोग करते हैं। हां। अब आपके लिए
एक टास्क है। आज के सेशन में। टास्क कुछ
भी नहीं है। टास्क बस इतना टास्क है। बहुत
सिंपल सा टास्क है। बहुत सिंपल सा टास्क
है।
कि मैंने आपको जैसा बोला कि आप किसी भी
एसओसी के वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाकर
WhatsApp ग्रुप को जरूर ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा
और WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
Lindin पे की पॉइंट्स बना के जो भी आपने
आज सीखा है की पॉइंट्स बना के Lindin पे
डालिएगा और मुझे या डेफोनिक्स को टैग कर
दीजिएगा। एंड जब आप वीडियो रिकॉर्डिंग को
वापस से देख लें तो कमेंट्स में इसी
वीडियो के आके अपना फुल नेम और आपने
क्या-क्या आपने आपका फुल नेम और आपने सीख
लिया। यह कमेंट कर दीजिएगा। मतलब आपने
लर्न कर लिया, सीख लिया, आपने कंप्लीट कर
लिया। यह भी कमेंट कर दीजिएगा। यह काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है। एंड जो टॉपिक्स मैंने आपको
यहां पे आज बताया है। व्हाटएवर टॉपिक्स आई
हैव टॉट यू। इसके बारे में एक्सप्लोर
एक्सप्लोर करना है खुद से भी। अब जैसे
मैंने ईडीआर बताया तो थोड़ा सा आपको ईडीआर
के बारे में एक्सप्लोर करना है। एक्सडीआर
बताया। एक्सडीआर के बारे में एक्सप्लोर
करना है। हल्का-हल्का नॉलेज लेना है। मैं
सब बताऊंगा बट आपको भी हल्की-हल्की
एक्सप्लोर करनी है। ठीक है? एंटरप्राइज
प्लेटफार्म के बारे में बताया या
एक्सटेंडेड के बारे में बताया। उसके बारे
में आपको थोड़ा सा रिसर्च करना है। ये सब
चीजों के बारे में रिसर्च करना है। दैट्स
इट।
सर वाईटी पे टैग किया है आपको? अच्छा
YouTube पे टैग किया है। कौन से YouTube
पे टैग किया आपने? ठीक है। मैं देख लूंगा
अगर आपने टैग किया तो। थैंक यू।
प्लीज आंसर विदाउट एनी पेड सर्टिफिकेट
12th पास विद स्किल्स कैन गेट जॉब ऑफ एलन।
12th पास है सिर्फ आप तब तो आपको जॉब
मिलने की चांसेस बहुत कम है। इट्स वेरी
लेस चांसेस। सिर्फ 12th पास है तो बहुत कम
चांस है। मैं झूठ-मूठ का आपको क्यों
दिलासा दिलाऊं?
सर, क्या बीए डिग्री होने के बाद भी जॉब
मिल सकती है साइबर सिक्योरिटी में? थोड़ी
प्रॉब्लम्स आएंगी। मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि बीसीए करने की ट्राई कीजिए। अगर
आप बीसीए कर लेते हैं बीए के अलावा भी तो
इट विल हेल्प यू मच।
सर Lindin पे अटैक किया है। ओके ऋषु थैंक
यू। थैंक यू।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट देख
लेते हैं। अगेन।
सो हियर आर द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट। जो टॉप 50
के फैंस की लिस्ट है। दे डिर्व टू बी
नोटेड। ऋषु साइबर स्मार्ट मिस्टर रोबोट
कश्मीरा सलमान
मिस्टर जट प्रिंस खुशी
शाहिल आदेश कमल राकेश सजल बहुत सारे लोग
हैं साइबर ज्ञान अब सबके नाम नहीं डेफक
सबके नाम मैं नहीं ले सकता अमन शेख अभिषेक
गौरव
सीक्रेट टेक्नोलॉजी रोहित जीरो जीरो टी
सेक ऑफ कोड निशा चौधरी शुभम
ऋित्व अरे भाई सभी लोग हैं ये लोग ये लोग
जो हैं अ पीतांबर डिनोविजन
राधिका
एंड दीज़ ऑल दीज़ आर द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट थैंक
यू वेरी मच फॉर बीइंग कंस कंसिस्टेंट थैंक
यू वेरी मच फॉर अटेंडिंग द सेशंस अह एंड
यस
सर साइबर सिक्योरिटी में करियर करने के
लिए सीसीएनए एमसीएसए आरएससीएस आरएससी
स्किल होनी चाहिए है क्या? नहीं ऐसी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। है तो अच्छी बात है
बट ऐसी कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है।
कंप्यूटर डिप्लोमा अगर है तो देखो चांसेस
हैं बट स्टिल डिग्री की बात थोड़ी अलग
होती है। बहुत सारी कंपनीज़ डिग्री को
ज्यादा प्रेफरेंस देती है ओवर डिप्लोमा।
तो अगर उनके प्रेफरेंस में है डिग्री तो
वहां पे आप फिर कुछ नहीं कर सकते।
ओके?
चलिए ठीक है। ठीक है गाइस मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट सेशन में। आई होप कि आप आपको मजा
आया होगा इस सेशन के अंदर में। काफी अच्छा
लगा होगा एंड इंटरेस्टिंग लगा होगा। आप
हमारे डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी के
Lindin पेज को जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। इट्स
आवर कंपनी पेज। यहां पे आपको बहुत सारी
अपडेट्स मिलेंगी। Lindin पे जाके सिंपल आप
डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च कर लीजिएगा। यू विल गेट
आवर डिफरॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी पेज जहां
पे 20,000 से भी ज्यादा डिफ्रॉनिस्टर्स
एंड फॉलोवर्स हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए हैं।
यहां आपको सारी अपडेट्स एंड ऑल हमारी
कंपनीज़ के रिगार्डिंग जो भी चीजें हैं सब
आपको मिल जाएगी। इसको जरूर फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा और Instagram पे कनेक्ट हो
जाइएगा। डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे फॉलो अप कर
लीजिएगा जहां लगभग 500 हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए
हैं फॉलोअर्स। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। सो, आज
के सेशन को यहां एंड करते हैं। थैंक यू
वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन। बहुत जल्द
नेक्स्ट सेशन आपकी आएगी एंड उस सेशन में
भी आप आइएगा जरूर। मैं उम्मीद करता हूं कि
इतने 300 लोग के आसपास जरूर सब फिर से
आएंगे एंड धमाकेदार सेशन रखेंगे। अगला
सेशन और भी धमाकेदार होगा और भी
इंटरेस्टिंग होगा। जैसे-जैसे आगे बढ़ेगा
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होगा। और देखो अगर जॉब
रेडी ट्रेनिंग में भी अगर आप नहीं आ रहे
हो तो मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता। फिर मेरे बस
की बात नहीं है भाई समझाना। बस इतना बस आप
घर पे पूछ लीजिएगा। घर पे आप अपने
पेरेंट्स से पूछिए। घर पे अपने गार्डियन
पेरेंट्स से बात करके या जो भी आपसे बड़ा
है या जो जिससे भी आप सजेस्ट सजेशन लेना
चाहे आप उससे बात करके देखिए और उससे
पूछिए कि इस तरह की ट्रेनिंग चली है। क्या
मुझे करना चाहिए? बाकी काम छोड़ के वो
बोलेंगे हां करना चाहिए तो बस दैट्स इट सर
आई एम स्पीचलेस थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू ओके
गाइस तो थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द
सेशन मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में बहुत
जल्द मिलेंगे एंड बहुत जल्द डिपेंड करता
है आपकी एक्टिविटी पे और आपकी अवेलेबिलिटी
पे और आपके सेशन को अटेंड करने की लाइव
सेशन में आने की काउंटिंग पे कि कितनी
जल्दी-जल्दी हम क्लासेस लाएंगे। ठीक है?
तो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में। टिल देन
थैंक यू वेरी मच। गुड नाइट। गुड नाइट सभी
को। शुभ रात्रि एंड एंजॉय द नाइट एंड
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में। थैंक यू वेरी
मच। बाय।